Well
what?
What was that?
Hey,
hey,
how's everybody doing?
The fuck's going on.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is our newest sponsor and it's a very exciting one.
Blue Apron is a way that you can get food delivered to your house with recipes
to cook all the fresh ingredients delivered to your house.
You don't have to shop,
you don't have to do shit.
They send it in a cooler.
Here's how it works.
For 999 per meal,
they send you all the ingredients in the exact right proportions with simple
recipe instructions right to your door.
It's awesome.
I've tried it a couple of times now.
It's great the meals or 500 to 700 calories per serving,
which is pretty low for how delicious they are and there's a bunch of different
options too.
You can get a bunch of different things that that blue apron provides.
Like I'll read you off a list of stuff.
ASPARAGUS and spring onion,
tart beat and barley risotto,
orange glaze,
chicken drumsticks,
and you.
It's Kinda cool because you do it all yourself.
It's like a little project Maraca and beef 10 gene.
I hope I'm saying that right.
Five spice hanger steaks,
like really good food and you don't have to do any of the shopping.
You don't have to do any of that nonsense.
It's all delivered to your house.
It's fucking kick ass.
I really enjoy this.
Um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Cook some his shit up tonight too.
And the stress of cooking.
Ladies and gentlemen,
go to blue apron.com/rogan and get your first two meals for free.
That's right.
Two meals for just going to blue apron.com/rogan you cook incredible meals and
be blown away by the quality and the freshness.
Blue Apron,
fast,
fresh and affordable.
I'm very happy with this product.
I think it's an excellent idea.
I think it's amazing that nobody ever came up with it before but I'm glad these
guys did.
The way they put it together is,
is really well done too.
They've obviously planned this out and put a lot of thought into it.
The directions are super easy to follow and they have pictures like you don't
have to like think things through like a fucking like a dummy like me.
What was that?
Hmm.
Interesting.
Anyway,
cooking's a pain the Dick and this takes a lot of the pain out of it.
Go to blue apron.com/rogan and get your first two meals for free.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're also brought to you by ting.
Ting is a mobile service provider that uses the sprint backbone and what they do
is they rent time on the sprint backbone,
but they do it all by their rules.
No early termination fees,
no cancellation fees,
no.
You know you pay like overage fees,
they cut all that stupid shit out.
You're like most times you like pay like oh you get 120 minutes per month.
Well if you don't use the 120 minutes per month,
what happens?
They don't give you any money back and if you use it over 120 minutes per month,
you get penalized.
Well,
tank cut all that nonsense out and what they do is they just charge you for what
you use.
That's it.
And that's how it should be.
And if you're a heavy user,
you can save fuck load of money that way.
They've also slashed their prices.
They did it at the two year mark when they celebrated our two year anniversary
for no reason other than just they could,
they got better deals.
I said,
you know,
we're going to pass these deals onto the customers.
98% of people would save money on tank,
especially people who are power users.
If you're online sending Dick pics all throughout the land,
if you're one of those motherfuckers Tang is your Jim Norton.
I'm looking at you,
Jim.
Tig is your mobile service provider,
Ladies and gentlemen,
$21 is the average monthly bill per device for 10 customers and they have some
kick ass phones also,
when you buy a phone from Ting,
you own that shit and you can get some cheap ass phones too.
You can get an LG optimists for 42 bucks and it's done.
It's yours.
You own that fucker.
You can get flip phones.
They have a Samsung m 400 if you one of those contrarion assholes,
the likes,
those flip phones,
I don't even use email man.
Those fuckers get one of those are 72 bucks or you can get the top of the line.
Android phones like the Samsung Galaxy s five they have that.
If you're kind of a little bit of a cheap steak cheapskate,
you can get the Samsung Galaxy s four be one of those guys.
You can get the HTC one m eight they have that.
They have the galaxy note three they have a lot of killer android phones
including iPhone five for just 331 bucks.
Come on folks.
How are you going to go wrong there?
It's an awesome company with great ethics behind it and nothing but positive
feedback from all the customers.
Everybody that's used tanning that I've referred to has said they've saved
money.
They really enjoy the service.
They enjoy the company and it's a good relationship.
They liked the relationship that they get.
You know when you like when a company like feels like they've given you a good
deal,
it feels like it feels good to be involved with them.
And that's how I feel about tank.
Go to rogan.ting.com and get $25 off of your first android device.
That is the official,
uh,
cell phone provider of this podcast.
It's what I use for the,
um,
for the actually for the show,
for when I give the number out to people and people call in and when we set
things up,
everything's done through the tank phone.
Love it,
love it,
love it.
Love it.
rogan.ting.com save yourself 25 bucks.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n I t a human optimization website.
We sell strength and conditioning equipment.
We sell supplements,
we sell foods,
foods.
What kind of food?
Why God Google,
Google lead Mowgli.
We have now.
We just started carrying on it.
Coffee.
Um,
this is made for us by caveman coffee.
It is a single estate coffee,
which means it's made and produced in one place and then sold to us.
Um,
they,
they roasted,
they pick it,
they do the whole Jamey and a caveman coffee,
which is owned bar buddy Tait Fletcher and Keith Jardeen,
two excellent human beings.
And um,
we have our own blend.
It's a Colombian amber blend,
handcrafted by caveman coffee.
Handcrafted a term I fucking deeply despise and I'm getting really sick of
seeing handcrafted beverages.
You know,
like handcrafted cocktails are handcrafted burger.
Fuck you just shut up with your handcrafted anyway.
Uh,
are handcrafted coffees.
Awesome.
Did I mention that?
Go to [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n I t.
Get yourself some kettle bells.
Get yourself in shape and use the codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
Why?
Fuck around ladies and gentlemen,
Young Jim Norton is here and we're going to get down to the nitty gritty.
Critical to you getting ready.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
What a week young Jim Norton has had what a week?
Yes.
What a week.
Sirius satellite radio has had what a week censorship has had.
Anthony Kumina has had what a week.
All the people online,
they love the bitch and Piss and Moan and complain and get very excited when
something fucked up goes down.
Yeah.
Well something fucked up.
Went down when,
if you're listening to this,
if,
if at sometime in the future,
uh,
cause these recordings will be saved forever.
This is today's date is July 17th,
2014 approximately a week go Anthony Ku.
Mia was taken photographs,
Anthony of the opiate Anthony Show,
which our pal Jim Norton is also a part of was he was downtown in New York,
taken some photographs.
And from there on it's a bunch of,
you know what he says and what I'm sure the woman who beat the shit out of them
would have a different story.
But he was taking some photographs.
One of,
one of the photographs was of this,
uh,
what are those things called when you,
those things we look at staffing,
scaffolding,
who's walking through the scaffolding?
A woman was coming towards him.
It looked like he was just taking a bunch of cool photos of New York.
There's a bunch of them that he put up on his Instagram.
Yeah.
Anyway,
this woman got upset that he was taking a photo of her,
probably thought that he was perving,
um,
got mad at them,
violence ensued.
She hit him and he went on Twitter and went on this rant about violence,
about the black community and their propensity for violence about this woman
calling her an animal,
but what she did and a serious fired him and which left a fucking huge hole.
And uh,
my entertainment world,
uh,
the opiate,
Anthony shows my all time favorite radio show.
I listened to it all the time and now all of a sudden it is no more.
Yeah,
it's a,
you know,
it's,
it's a huge hole too.
Like I no one panicked.
Like may cause opie and Anthony both have kind of fuck you money.
Jim Norton doesn't.
So selfishly thinking,
I'm like,
well there goes everything because the show done well.
You are always going to be great because you're a funny comic and you can always
work and you never have to worry about that.
But um,
it is a crazy thing,
uh,
that,
you know,
all of a sudden like
that for things that he said on the show a hundred times.
I think what happened,
I started,
I think what happened was he tweeted,
like he told,
I talked to him multiple times since then.
He was walking and people don't believe that he was actually taking legitimate
in New York photos.
That was one of the points of contention.
People like he was being creepy,
but he really wasn't like Anthony has had this giant Hubble like camera in the
studio every day for probably six months now he's getting into photography.
It's what he's been doing.
So that was not unusual at all to hear.
He was out and about taking photos.
That's legit.
And I guess this woman got angry and I talked to him and he said that she just
said something like,
you,
you know this white boys,
take my picture,
you white motherfucker,
whatever.
She said she clocked him and he kept defending himself.
And as he's putting his arms up,
she is going,
um,
don't touch me.
Like,
you know,
that thing like that a woman might do to prevent you from hitting her,
like,
and you could see how frightening that would be.
Cause then then people think you're beating on this woman.
Right.
So he's putting his hand up and you know,
I know him well enough to know he's not going to just punch a woman in the
phase.
So she's doing that.
And I think a few black guys came around and they didn't do anything to amp,
but they were like,
you know,
don't touch her.
So,
um,
you know,
and who has always armed and he's licensed to carry,
um,
didn't hit her.
It didn't pull out his pistol and a went home and I guess was really upset and
went out on,
like you said,
a Twitter rampage.
And,
um,
I knew it was bad the next morning when I saw it because my ex girlfriend called
me and she's like,
what happened with Anthony?
He got beat up by a woman and there,
I don't know.
So I looked and I saw the tweets.
I'm like,
Oh,
I actually texted him about one.
I don't think I've ever done that before.
There was one that I texted her around that comes that you all right man,
does it?
He's like,
yeah,
I'm fine.
I'm gonna Cocoa.
It was scary.
Wow.
Um,
yeah.
The,
the thing about aunt is he's developed this sort of style of communicating on
the show where he goes on these long,
hilarious,
entertaining profanity filled rants.
And there's one thing about hearing it,
but there's another thing of like seeing it in a text form is this is not the
same.
It looks at things don't,
don't look good in print.
Certain things.
And I think what happened was,
is in the middle of like when you have,
you have a contextual conversation,
it's like you have people,
there's inflection,
there's another guy next to you going,
well,
hey,
what do you mean by that?
And then you're clarifying it or it's just,
it's a different energy when you're tweeting and you're that mad.
Like,
I think he like any type of an assault,
even if it's a woman hitting you and it's not life threatening,
it's still like an hour later you're like,
what the fuck just happened?
Like I think it just freaked him out and she hit him a couple times,
five times or so,
and he showed me pictures of his face and he had like a little,
you could see that he had been struck him and he wasn't making it up.
And so he went on and when I looked at the,
the,
the flow of things,
like I know Anthony and I know what he's saying.
He was not calling all black people animals.
He wasn't,
because he's never said that.
He's talking about a behavior of this woman.
And I think that what happened was he was so mad.
And when you're tweeting that aggressively and you've just,
you're fucking dealing with this in your head that sometimes things come out
jumbled and muddied.
And like,
if you know aunt,
you know what he's saying?
People who don't know,
I'm reading this going,
what does he mean?
He's saying that there's violence in black people and their animals,
like people are putting these pieces of a puzzle together and they're making a
picture and it was like,
it just,
I know him well enough to know that in a conversation if someone said,
are you trying to say black people or animals,
he would go,
no,
not at all.
It's a bay behavioral based that,
you know what I mean?
Cause you said that about white people too.
So I mean it was just one of those things where once it was in print,
it's even in context,
we lie as a country like you know like when cancel Colbert came out the,
the activist knew the context that he was making those Asian jokes and didn't
give a fuck.
She still wanted to sink him.
She's like,
no,
I get it.
He was trying to,
you know,
showed the difference between the,
the,
the same thing between this and native Americans and how ridiculous says but I
don't care.
So we've gotten to a point now where we don't even pretend to not understand the
context anymore.
We admit that we understand the context that we go after people anyway.
So something like this is bound to,
uh,
to sink you because it can be taken both ways unless you actually sit there and
talk to the guy and each tweet has to come out like a film.
Each tweet has to be a beginning,
middle,
and end with no explanation needed around it in order to,
to be survivable,
if that makes sense.
Well,
you know what,
the big,
big key to what you said that it could sink you will,
it only syncs you if you work for a company.
And in my opinion,
that's unnecessary in this day and age,
it's unnecessary.
And I think you guys,
and I think Anthony for sure would be far better off with a podcast.
Anybody can get a podcast and put it on their phone.
Now everybody's phone has a little Jack that sticks in your car and you play
your phone through your car.
Everybody has that now.
I mean,
it's not an uncommon thing.
It's more common to have that Jack than it is to have satellite radio.
Most people have to get a satellite radio thing installed in their car.
Most people already have that Jack,
you know,
it's just,
it's so God damn easy.
And I get,
I bet you could get all the same sponsors.
I bet you could get all of the same sponsors and you would have no middleman and
you don't look at the studio.
It's not,
it doesn't take much to put something together.
You know,
a little bit of time,
a little bit of effort.
You know,
you gotta know someone who's an engineer,
know someone who knows how to put this stuff together and set up the
microphones.
But other than that,
what's the difference between this and satellite radio?
I'll tell you what,
the differences,
nobody can fucking fire you.
You can go on some con rampage that fucking animal con and no one,
you know,
people might say,
I'm not downloading your podcast anymore,
but at least you have the opportunity to communicate,
to explain yourself.
And if the people decide that they don't like your character based on one thing
that you said or one rant that you went on,
that is their decision.
But it's not the decision of a company.
And when things get Kino companies are squirrely man,
they have fucking and stocks and they have responsibilities and all you need is
a few activists that start web pages and you know,
fire Anthony and Anthony can,
we were going after those sponsors,
we're going to let them know we're boycotting but mostly just noise.
Mostly nonsense.
Mostly just soft targets.
But all you need is a few of those in up a fucking accompany will panic.
They do.
What happens is,
you know,
to $1 billion company,
so you get guys like you know Scott and Jim who runs it,
who you know,
they're just the 4th of July weekend was coming and then all of a sudden they're
getting phone calls from the New York Post and the Washington Post,
although all the press obviously has a narrative and they did a shit job.
But the Washington Post I thought was the worst offender with the way they
covered it.
Cause the woman wrote things.
It was just really,
it was revolting to read,
which she right.
She was talking about Anthony saying that these guys came around and she was
saying like,
oh,
well I guess if a bunch of African American where,
how was she?
Said a bunch of gentlemen want to defend that someone from defaming,
an African American woman.
It's okay.
Like that's what was happening.
She wasn't acknowledged and Anthony was being hit.
She acted like that.
These guys had read his Twitter feed and not like it.
It was just like she read the Twitter feed in them in the future.
It was repulsive about this.
Well,
a woman who looks like the fucking fake deaf interpreter from Mandela's funeral
was beating on Anthony,
but a
fucking,
that's a meme.
That guy's a meme.
He's rules.
But,
uh,
the company that these guys just getting,
all of the sudden they're just there.
They're home and they're getting phone calls in the office the day before
vacation.
So what are your comments?
And they probably weren't even that familiar with it until they getting calls
from the paper and they're like,
what do we do with this?
And then this is what the press does and this is why you got to hate them
because I think Sirius was going to try to write it out.
That's my opinion.
Cause they knew a holiday weekend was coming.
And uh,
I,
this is purely a guess because no one was saying anything.
And then all of a sudden the press starts going,
we have not had a comment from Sirius satellite radio.
So we're assuming that they agree with Mr. Coleman has opinions.
They do this sneaky shit to push you into defending yourself.
So now the company with shareholders,
like you said,
it has to go,
well,
how do we tell people that we don't agree with?
So it's not like if the press is the made them do it,
but the press understands how to corner you into giving a statement,
a definitive statement,
cause they know that you're not used to this.
They know that these guys come into work,
uh,
in management positions are not used to getting phone calls going.
How do you feel about this statement and that statement?
You know,
it was really,
it was a very frustrating thing when I saw at the press did with it that that to
me is always who my biggest complaint is with always it's wordpress.
This is no nuance to the way they report on certain things like this cause
there's,
there's nuance to this,
especially if you look into it and character.
If you in context rather if you understand that guy and you,
you look at him.
Look,
there is a problem with violence in the black community to pretend there's not a
problem with violence in the black community is to pretend that there aren't
insane amounts of murders going on in Chicago to that there's not issues with
the amount of black people that are in jail.
The percentage of the population now are those economic problems,
are those problems related to upbringing?
Are those pro yes.
Education?
Yes,
absolutely.
There's a lot of fucking disparity.
There's a lot of problems with poverty.
There's a lot of problems with the structure of our culture itself and that you
could attribute a lot of those problems to racism,
to racism in the way that funds are allocated.
The way that you know,
the attention that society puts on impoverished communities.
Absolutely institutionalized,
yes.
But to pretend that it's not a problem is ridiculous.
It's fucking ridiculous.
So when he's taking a picture of some chick and she starts punching him,
I think he's allowed to talk about the problem with violence,
with that community,
with the community that this person is from that's beating him up.
Did he do it the right way?
No,
absolutely not.
Did he do it in a way that can be misconstrued or construed or interpreted as
racist?
Absolutely did.
Yeah,
he did.
He fucked up.
He did it the wrong way.
He probably shouldn't have done it on Twitter.
You probably should have made a video.
You probably should have made a video explaining,
showing what happened to him and explaining what goes on.
Explaining this 140 fucking characters things.
He's a big part of the problem it would add.
So that's exactly what it was.
Because Anthony is so good at clarify.
Whenever you talk about race or a million other things,
whether it's religion,
it's so hard to make your point without stepping in shit and then having to go
off on 50 a digression.
I was like,
oh no,
that's not what I meant him.
No,
that's not what I meant.
Like,
and that's the worst part of discussing stuff is that people jump on the side.
What are you saying that all people do?
And we'll all black too.
No,
I'm not.
So in order to be able to get your point across,
you have to walk a narrow,
you almost have to close people's argument doors,
like a get smart episode.
As you're walking this way,
your point gets through.
And Anthony is a genius at doing that.
A genius at it because we've debated race so many times,
uh,
on,
on the show at him.
But trace,
we'd go back and forth and,
and Patrice loved Anthony Cause he said Anthony,
he's an adorable racist.
You know,
Patrice was so funny with,
he never,
no,
never was upset by Anthony's opinions because Anthony would listen to him and
they would go back and forth.
Half The Times Patrice was right and half the time Anthony was right.
But on Twitter I think like,
like in that emotion when you're saying x,
Y and Z,
he,
I don't think he did as good a job as he should have done of closing those doors
behind him.
Almost like sealing off things that people can get to you on because he was so
upset because he had had a physical assault.
And I know it sounds like I'm talking in circles and just defending my friend,
but I've been with him for 10 years in this medium of totally uncensored.
And I'm telling you,
I know him well enough to know that he's like,
he's got weird things where he'll talk about race and people misinterpret them
and I've talked to him privately and the guy does not hate black people and I
know that that's just all his friends defending him.
But I'm telling you that he does not because I know him well.
And then to hear people going,
he hates black people.
It's like he's in this not afraid of being misconstrued or interpreted as
racist.
He's not afraid of it by saying what he really believes is his opinion about
certain aspects of a group,
whatever,
uh,
race,
gender,
whatever it is.
He's not afraid of speaking his mind about things because he's got that fuck you
money.
That's a big part of it.
And he's got 150,000 guns.
Those are the two things.
And you know,
a big part of it that drove me fucking crazy is people are not,
they're not taking into account the reaction that someone has when they get
assaulted.
Because when you get hit by someone,
some fucking stranger that you don't know hits you as specially when you've got
a gone,
you've got a fucking bullet launching gun,
you've got a thing inside you that has explosions,
you press a trigger,
explosions propelled bullets and they end lives instantly.
And Anthony's an expert with one and he has it on him at all times and he's
getting hit and he's like,
what the fuck?
And so he gets on left fucking animal con.
Yeah Bitch,
fuck you this back.
You know,
it's getting hit is a very disturbing thing.
It's,
I mean,
there's one thing to get hit and it's like getting hit in a sparring session is
infuriating with people.
And I've seen people go fucking crazy cause they get choked out in a Jujitsu
session,
getting punched his way,
more traumatic,
getting punched by a stranger multiple times for taking a fucking photograph.
I don't know what the exchange was between the two of them.
I don't know.
You know,
if,
if he was saying something that was infuriating,
I don't know.
I've,
I wasn't there,
you know,
I'm not gonna pretend I was there.
But man,
you've got to take into account the reaction that people have when you hit them.
And it would it to me,
and again,
I hate to keep going back to the press,
but they didn't focus on the fact that he,
like he handled himself properly in that because I know I would,
I don't know if I would have pulled the gun in that moment,
but I'm a panicky Pete and I would just been,
what other guys were coming over,
I would have at least brandished it.
And he acted physically responsible like as a,
as a,
as a fucking guy with a pistol on him.
Cause people get shot all the time for dumb arguments and dumb things.
He,
he handled himself absolutely right and lost his cool once he got home and uh,
people didn't take the press,
didn't take that into account.
They hopped on the fact that he didn't get a police report.
And I wished he had.
Now in hindsight,
because they're all going,
Mr Colby,
did I get a police report?
But here's the deal.
Had he gotten a police report,
they would have just ignored it.
They wouldn't have said,
well at least he got a police report.
They would have glanced over the fact and then said,
yeah,
well I ain't look and get a police report,
so they would just using that as a reason to kind of ignore the fact that he got
hit.
They're like,
oh,
we didn't see a police report.
All the press harped on the fact that he didn't get a police report,
but Ansi response was,
look man,
you know,
I know enough cops to know that me getting hit by some lady in Times Square is
not a fucking priority for Nyp d who's worried about terrorists.
Yeah,
especially if he's fine.
I think there's a real issue also with the press
with a lot of people in the press.
I'll clarify that.
What they're trying to do is they're trying to close those get smart doors as
they write a piece as well,
and as they're writing a piece,
they are also trying to placate all the people that are going to be up in arms
about their opinions.
If they could possibly be supporting a racist,
if they could possibly be taking his side,
agreeing with him,
seeing his point of view,
they could be misinterpreted or they could be interpreted as being racist as
well.
So they have to worry about that as well.
Especially if you're with a liberal rag,
you know,
if you have a very liberal newspaper that you work for and they have a clear
agenda,
which a lot of them do,
the Washington Times does,
right.
I'll wash it.
Absolute washing post does.
There's a lot of them that have a liberal slant and if you are reporting for
them,
you know,
and it's something like this that's very controversial and something where
there's,
there's a bunch of things that automatically have like a knee jerk reaction to
them.
And this is one of them knee jerk reaction to what's conceived as racist.
It perceived as racist.
Yes.
And,
and another thing that they do that's even,
that's even more enraging is what people who write for the press now have to do
is not just reporting what happened.
It's how do I editorialize under the guise of being impartial.
And they do that a lot too and that I don't like either.
It's like that to me is the worst crime they commit.
Actually.
It's the editorializing as they're going along.
Like it's legitimate.
Like,
uh,
like NBC and I'm on a Zimmerman Fan.
Either aunt was a big supporter.
Zimmerman,
I thought Zimmerman should have went to jail for something.
I didn't know what legally I have no ground to stand on,
but I kind of thought he was a con,
but a but button on a guy who was out to commit a murder or either,
I thought there was a line in between,
but whatever,
like NBC edited that tape like Eh,
can't do.
There's no reason to do that unless you're pushing something.
But they're doing it under the guise of being impartial and I'm sure they've
done it plenty of times to vilify blacks.
I'm not saying they haven't,
he lost that lawsuit,
you know?
I know he did crazy.
It's crazy.
It's absolutely nuts.
I don't know why the news has such a different level of what they can get away
with and what they can do because they're seen as doing a public service.
In my opinion though,
I think they lost it because everybody was hating that guy and they just want,
they didn't want him to win something on top of this.
The fact that he's still has his freedom,
the kid lost his life.
I think he's,
I think he's a sucky fucking security guard.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
I think if you're going to look at that guy and find fault and what he did,
it's how did he handle the situation and what a more confident,
competent person have handled it the same way.
Like here's a perfect example.
My friend big John McCarthy who was a cop,
I guarantee you,
you know the referee.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That guy was a cop a long time,
but great guy,
but knows how to handle shit.
If Big John McCarthy saw that kid walking in the neighborhood,
he probably would have said,
how you doing man?
Everything cool.
You know,
it had a conversation with him.
Everything would've been fine.
Like even if the kid got up in arms or got mouthy with them,
he would have probably calmed them down,
you know,
without having to get into some physical altercations.
Not only the kid wouldn't have been able to mount them and bash his fucking head
off the ground because he's physically in competent.
If you're going to fucking could patrol the neighborhood,
you can't do it just with a gun,
right.
Can't be,
you can't have the only,
the last resort is your only resort.
You keep,
can't physically defend himself.
He's out of shape.
He's soft and doughy and he's not physically able to hold that guy off.
But yet he's put himself in this position where he's like a security.
He's the force of,
of,
of the truth of the law.
You can't do that.
You know,
you're not,
you're not qualified for that job.
He's just not.
So when that kid's on top of him bouncing his fucking head off the curb,
look,
I don't see any way out for him other than using a weapon right when that kid is
beating the shit out of him.
But he should have never gotten to that position.
He should've never,
it should've never escalated to that.
You're telling me the only way to people can communicate like that is it comes
into violence.
No,
it,
it's how do you deal with it?
How do you communicate?
How did you address this person?
What did you say when he talked back to you?
What did you say?
What was,
what were the exchange of words?
You know,
and those,
those things.
There's a big difference between,
there's a video that we played the other day.
Um,
was there some,
the,
uh,
do you even lift bro?
You ever see that guy?
The Russian guy?
Is He Russian?
There's even a worst one though.
I don't know.
The Pakistani kids though,
in New York where the Bronx,
the police chief in Bronx,
New York was like,
stop doing it.
You're going to get killed.
That like these two kids had just gone to youtube and they go up to people and,
and horrible neighborhoods and are like,
hey man,
you got a problem while he's holding a calculator and he's just trying to be
funny.
But these guys are just bashing their heads in and stuff and said the Bronx,
a chief police or something.
Like I said,
look,
stop it.
But yeah,
these videos,
my point is if you watch those videos,
the guy,
he comes up to,
people that look like they work out and goes,
do you even lift bro?
Look how small you are.
And some people handle it.
Great.
Some people go,
you know,
like,
man,
I don't even,
don't pull it up.
We don't need to see it.
Some people go,
yeah,
I mean I don't even lift,
you know,
I guess I'm small.
And then they laugh and they walk away.
And some people like threatened them.
Like it,
it depends entirely on how to people interact with each other.
Yeah.
And I think that's what we don't know about the Anthony situation.
That's what we don't know about the Zimmerman situation.
It's not just about what went down,
it's about how did it all play out,
how could it have been avoided?
There's little subtleties in language like when Jonah Hill is apologizing
recently.
Um,
and he's,
he,
and he's obviously not a homophobe.
We just got mad and said,
suck my Dick Faggot.
It was a stupid thing in a moment.
And he's at the tonight show and again,
he's just apologizing is I don't think he never had to deal with something like
this.
And he said something.
He goes,
man,
the intent doesn't matter.
It's the word,
the words.
And it was like,
again,
I know you're on the spot in that moment and I'm not going to crucify the guy,
but I wish I was there so I could just appear on the seat next to him.
Like in that woody Allen scene,
when the guy walks out to correct the guy on line and go,
no,
the intent is everything.
Because if the words don't matter the next time somebody said the fucking giants
killed the jets,
well we'd better call the police.
Oh,
that's right.
It's the intent.
We understand every,
every,
every single interaction or phrase has an intent behind it,
which,
which doesn't always come through in the written word.
It's just that it's an inflection and that's something that you and I had a
conversation about with the Tracy Morgan situation with the people pretending
that what he was saying when he was on stage,
you know that he was going to stab a sign of his son was gay.
Like his whole act is filled with him saying ridiculous shit.
This is not a statement.
It's not an affidavit.
He's making court.
You're,
you're taking it out of context because it's a soft target.
If you do that,
yes,
I'm going to stab my son because he's gay.
As a statement of fact or at the,
at the end of a political rally is a pretty awful thing to say,
but if you've opened up with I'm going to get you pregnant and I'm going to mold
shit and make a hat out of it,
it's kind of hard to take any one statement and go,
well that's the serious one.
But that's again,
that's that purposely ignoring context or even when you can't ignore it saying,
yeah,
we understand the context and we don't fucking care.
It's just soft targets.
People find soft targets and those targets,
look,
if they're all ganging up on Anthony too.
That's the other thing.
I'm not saying Boo Hoo Anthony,
let's pay attention to what's really going on.
If you're writing an article out of the blue for no reason about Jim Norton,
you,
you're the only guy,
I think Jim Norton is a despicable person and you write this article,
you have the option to respond to that and you can go,
well,
who are you mister reporter,
Dick Wad.
Let's take a look at you.
And then other people can take a look at him too.
But when everybody's piling on,
it's a free for all.
It's a free ride and then you're there flailing wildly.
All the Louie Louie CK actually raised a really good point about that.
When something has happened,
he goes,
you know,
you have to remember too,
everybody's not googling you.
Like everyone is not googling Joe Rogan or Jim Norton or Anthony Kumi at like,
so you're seeing,
uh,
every result of that yourself and it appears overwhelming.
But the reality is like people may be reading news day or the post or the Gawker
or vice or you know,
whatever they're reading,
but they're not reading every single article on Anthony Kumiai or on Jim Norton.
So it,
that's where the overwhelming thing is sometimes misleading because people are
all reading little snippets of it.
But when you know,
the company is getting calls from again,
five or six different outlets to them and feels overwhelming and like what the
fuck do we do with this because this wasn't on the air.
So I think that's what,
and again,
they haven't discussed this with me,
I'm,
I'm purely speculating because to them,
if it was on the air,
I'm guessing they would have said,
well that's what he does on the air.
But they're not looking at it like,
well he was reacting to being hit.
I think they just were like,
oh okay we got to fire him.
Like I think that's why they,
they kind of just reacted very quickly.
I think they fucked themselves.
I really do.
They fucked themselves cause they were supposed to be the place where it was
free speech.
This is the wild place.
But we're the virus.
There was the virus channel member.
Now it's Sirius Xm talk.
That's it is Sirius XM talk.
We have to rename it but we don't know what would they have to,
they have to ask you fly input.
I don't want my name on the show.
Like I want,
I want to be on this show,
but I don't want to be ob and Jimmy.
I don't people to feel like I'm jumping into Anthony's seat cause I'm not,
um,
if they call it opie show,
I'm much more with that
because that's what it was before he met Anthony.
Cool.
Me How it call we Ms. Anthony.
Uh,
yeah,
that would be kind of a,
or Tony will call Tony so they don't know who we're talking about.
What to say.
Bring where's Tony?
And it'll be sneaky.
But again,
it is a horrible,
and it's like people get mad at me and opiate.
It's like we don't,
I tried to say like,
we didn't mad at you for what?
Because the,
the people think that we're like a bunch of teenagers hanging out and like you
guys should walk in support and it's like,
first of all,
you know dumb motherfuckers that say that Anthony I've talked to,
he wouldn't walk and he told me,
dude,
you got to make your money like,
and it's all a and B,
I'm under contract.
I can't just walk.
I have three more months in the contract.
And Ob tried to clear this up on the air.
Like if we just walk out,
if they don't fire us and we just walk and say a bunch of more subs leave cause
they realize like,
wow,
the show really is gone,
then all of a sudden serious wants to take action on us for breach.
It's a whole fucking illegal.
People just don't get that part of it.
And they think that we're fucking Anthony.
You know,
who doesn't think we're fucking Anthony Anthony?
He knows we're not fucking,
only an idiot thinks you're fucking Anthony,
but there's always going to be idiots with opinions out there.
And I'm fine with that.
When people say like,
Dude,
I love you and Opie,
but I got to cancel because I'm staying with Anthony.
I don't get mad at those people or people like I'm going to keep serious and I'm
also going to listen to ant.
I don't bog.
I'm fine with that too because I get the emotion like whatever they got to do to
support and is cool with me,
I want them to stay because my,
in my ideal world,
they listen to me an opie and then they fucking listen to Anthony.
There's no competition.
I'm not going to,
we're not like here you don't mention Anthony.
You don't want to fucking shell comes out.
I'm going to,
I'm going to tweet it because I want him to succeed cause he's one of my closest
friends.
It's going to succeed.
It's going to,
if you,
you know,
just,
he's an entertaining guy.
He's an interesting guy in the platform of the Internet is so free and easy and
he's already got a full professional set up at his house.
Yeah.
People don't know if you've never seen.
One of the main reasons I started this podcast is because of live from the
compound because he set up fucking greenscreen in his house,
a professional studio,
and he was playing images behind him of like the city of like he had a green
screen,
I mean a beautiful green screen po like professional broadcast quality cameras,
like the whole deal.
I was like,
that's amazing.
And that slowly but surely led to what you're seeing right here.
Like him doing that while he was already on Sirius and Sirius tried to stop him
from doing that.
They got it.
They gave him a hard time about that.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
that was it.
I think that was a contractual issue too where they're like,
look,
this is the medium you're on.
But eventually they like,
they're kind of like,
let them do it and they're like,
uh,
it's only,
it would only help the show.
It's just more,
more advertising,
more people paying attention,
more entertainment,
you know,
it's going to get more people that,
I mean,
that's what people are realizing about the Internet.
bars.
Earlage got all upset at Metallica fans for downloading his shit and it created
this huge shit storm.
You know where everybody's
like,
dude,
don't you have enough fucking money?
Like we,
you're worried about people downloading your shit.
More people going to come see you in concert.
And that's what it really has turned out to be for all musical artists.
Yeah,
you're not selling as many records,
but you're going to get more fans and there's more people going to see you in
concert.
And guess what?
That's all your money when you,
when you can set that up and have people just come out and see you in concert,
that's actually better.
I didn't mind.
I'll tell you why I didn't mind large doing that because I think that he kind of
say it.
What was happening is with the music industry was not prepared for the onslaught
of downloads.
And again,
they're greedy.
Twats the,
I mean the business,
not the artists,
but the fucking guys behind the scenes.
They've been raping artists for years.
Fucking taking all their money.
But we had it not because I think iTunes was born of the idea of Napster falling
through.
So it's like,
I kinda like it because now I can go buy a song or two songs.
Like I'm not going to download a whole fucking Nicki Minaj album,
but there's one song you're like fucking minutes looking ass Nigga is the
fucking greatest song ever done.
It's the fucking greatest thing ever done.
I don't want to buy the whole album,
but that fucking video is ha is sexy railing.
I dude,
I fucking love that song.
I for real love it.
It's great.
And that I would buy it.
I don't want to buy the whole dumb.
I wish we could play it,
but we'll get pulled over you.
It's a song you can't sing.
Also with the windows down to I found out recently,
it's a lot of inwards.
Yes,
it really is.
But the eye,
the lying she uses in that a fucking great.
And I love the song.
So that's just an example.
Like I can't buy that whole album and I like it for my own dumb little cds that
are on iTunes.
I liked the fact that can make some money there and they're not just going to,
people are still going to steal them pie.
You know,
this is still brilliant people out there,
but the majority of people aren't computer geniuses.
They just,
oh I'll go to iTunes for a buck and buy a couple of trends like that.
Kind of like if it's easy to do,
people are going to pay for it.
It's easy to one click on Amazon.
People who pay for one click on iTunes.
Yes,
that's,
you know,
that's the way to do it.
Make it so it's convenient.
Make it,
I mean I think eventually you're going well you're always going to have people
that have digital copies of things,
online stuff.
It's always going to be the case,
but people are getting more and more hesitant to do that because a lot of people
are getting fucked.
Like people that are downloading illegal parting of the UFC as they're getting
sued.
People that have downloaded movies are getting sued.
People that upload movies,
like a lot of those guys that had like a bunch of movies that they were sharing
on bit torrent,
they're getting sued for fuckloads of money,
man.
And,
and,
and people are like,
why are they going after the little guy?
Here's why.
Because when the little guy starts to have to,
people say,
you can get sued,
I,
they can't win.
Oh,
okay.
That's how it happens.
You walk into court and go,
your honor,
they can't win.
And he goes,
you're right.
No charge.
No,
you've got to pay for a fucking lawyer.
And a lawyer is a 20 grand hit minimum.
So the average person,
when they have to get an attorney and they realize this is going to cost me
10,000,
$20,000 just to defend,
they don't want to deal with it.
So a lot,
that's a lot of times that's what these little lawsuits are about.
It's getting just to back
off and discouraging.
Well,
I got errors and omissions insurance because of a conversation I have with you.
You told me about it.
Yeah.
And when you were getting sued,
yes.
It's,
um,
it's a very frustrating process because you realize the legal process is not
free even if it,
even if you think you're in the right,
but in a way it's saved me I think in the long run,
that experience because now I have it for everything.
I do my books,
DVDs,
cds,
I get everything vetted and I have like $3 million worth of insurance,
which is probably a panicky overkill on my part.
But I do that because you want to protect yourself even from a,
uh,
what's the word?
Not Frugal,
frivolous litigation.
I don't know who's going to come after me.
Somebody may hear something and then it may cause him to bang their fucking head
into the wall and then say,
I caused an autistic reaction or I caused the fucking,
I was the one,
I was the one Al Roker made fun of the,
uh,
you know the liver.
Yeah,
no,
the Olympic logo is causing some kind of a epileptic epileptics,
whatever it is,
someone can always file the suit and you have to pay to defend it.
So that type of shit.
It's nice to have,
you know,
that really does happen.
Yes.
There was a dude that I had on my podcast.
His wife was an epileptic,
not on my podcasts,
on my message board.
His wife was an epileptic and uh,
someone who had a logo that was like flashing and he started complaining about
it,
you guys need to take that down.
So then everybody put up a flashing logo.
It was of course,
but then he messaged me,
he's like,
seriously,
my wife sees that she'll faint,
so just go into a seizure.
And I was like,
come on.
So I had to look it up.
I was like,
yeah,
it does.
There's,
there was a certain television show that was going on in Japan.
It was like a kid's show.
It's the one with the mighty are the four guys power rangers?
Was it the power rangers?
Whatever it was.
This television show made kids have seizures for whatever reason.
Certain kids that have a certain issue,
they would watch these flashing things and just video games.
Now have that at the beginning.
Like if you played a video game like this game kid cost Caesar's,
if you have that,
if they used to have to warn you so and so you've been pre worn fucking weird by
the,
everything that we deal with,
it's annoying.
Everything is because of lawsuits.
So we kind of brought it on ourselves to like,
people are like,
why do they have to,
companies have to be so like I'll get annoyed.
It's serious sometimes like what the fuck?
And then I'm like,
oh yeah,
they have a shitload of people working for them and every one of them has access
to human resources and any one of those people could just go to human resources
and say this is a hostile work environment because of something,
you know these people like why can't we look at a girl's ass in the hallway?
Go ahead,
pinch your ass.
It gets 1950 and then when they sue the company,
the company's like,
what?
Like what the fuck we going to pay to defend this?
Because you couldn't keep your hands off her.
So as much as companies can drive me nuts.
Sometimes all of these protective barriers that have been put in place had been
because citizens have filed lawsuits,
some that were very legitimate,
like sexual harassment guys
have kind of pieces of shit with that.
I,
that was probably a bad example because most guys,
you know,
women have told me horror stories where they've got to deal with at work where
it's,
yeah,
it's more than just a glance,
like it's,
you know,
a guy rubbing his dick or while they're getting coffee and going,
Nah,
I'm kidding.
You know,
it's like,
how do you fucking deal with that if you're,
but you know,
the companies have to deal with this.
So then they put all this shit in place to protect themselves from these
litigious fucking shithead employees.
Yeah,
there's both,
right.
There's real scenarios where people are getting sexually harassed.
Uber fucked up.
You know,
could you imagine being a chicken and office and some guy you don't want to have
anything to do with consistently hits on you and tell dirty jokes and fucks with
you and asks you if you're gaining weight.
If you ignore them and say,
hey,
you know,
they started getting weird.
Guys are gross.
Creepy.
I'm so glad I'm not a check.
I couldn't imagine being a heterosexual woman having to deal with men who want
to fuck me,
or just the energy,
like the things that you can't prove in court,
but the energy of the guy who wants to fuck you,
dumb dick up against the fucking top of your desk.
Are you doing well?
I'm just saying hello.
You know you posted on what's the,
he's resting it.
Yeah,
it's called.
It's all mushed up fucking plump kids fucking making men and women work together
for eight hours in a row together in a,
in a closed in environment.
It's the automatic sexual tension between some folks.
It has to be,
yeah,
just there's no way around that man.
Now from a,
from a guy's point of view,
at least I think women are better because their whole thing is picking which
guys they want to fucking pee.
I think women are better at going out of this.
[inaudible] was professional and not to do that.
We're just awful lot of,
I know I'm awful at it,
but it's also like there's just a,
that's the social environment of the office.
There's always going to be weirdness.
Sure.
You know in the office and then if you have those fucking office parties where
people get a little liquored up and it all comes out that tonight he start
dancing and shit and little nuttiness and next thing you know people are getting
fucking sued.
Yeah.
You're dropping someone off and you want to have jerking off in front of her in
the car and she goes in and feels dirty.
Cause that happened for whatever big deal over here.
The frog worked together for six months already.
Fucking holiday parties.
Yeah,
I cleaned the dash.
come on,
touch you on it.
It,
but that's,
look,
we have female interns.
That's what keeps me from hitting on the Internet.
I'm fucking as Florentine,
which that Pete professional with the interns.
I don't fucking,
I'll joke with them on the air.
I don't fucking look at their asses in the hallway.
I don't flirt with them because a,
the most of our 21 and 22 I don't want one of them misinterpreting something and
going to human resources and going,
this 45 year old piece of garbage is hitting on me and then I'm going to sue
you.
And then the company is like,
we're going to get sued at what the fuck?
Because companies have lost a lot of money with that.
Oh yeah.
They've lost in legit cases,
but they don't want to take a chance.
So then they're going to fucking look at me and go one more time and you fall,
you know,
whatever.
So that's why I don't do it.
Another aspect of this crazy litigious society that we live in is patent trolls.
That's the thing that Adam going through right now.
When we're all a part of it and we're trying to help him raise money for his
legal funds,
it's going to cost him $1 million.
$1 million to defend against this patent troll.
Yeah.
And they,
they already had a hearing and during the hearing or they had whatever it is,
when they meet down and they discuss the merits of the case and the,
you know,
the cases essentially thought to be frivolous,
but they're still going forward with motion to dismiss.
That's why I tried to motion to dismiss and they said no.
So either,
I guess what they will do is go for my guests will be the next step or they can
go for summary Judgment,
uh,
maybe with a process,
all the facts and they say,
you know,
should we go into depositions or whatever.
And again,
it might be different in this kind of case,
but uh,
there's a lot of that's a,
that's a patent troll friendly area where they're from,
which is why I think that a lot of these people set up offices and that part of
Texas,
but fucking the supreme court just shot down.
They really hurt patent trolls saying something that you can't patent idea.
Like you can patent a method of delivering an idea when you can't patent the
idea of just like episodic things on the internet or,
or whatever it was that they said you can't do it.
What's,
let's give them a shout out here.
Cause my God has sent me this.
Uh,
he's the guy who runs a Adam show over there.
He sent me this thing about it and give you the whole though.
There's the full deal.
So far they have raised $425,000 for their,
um,
for their defense,
their most recent bill.
This is incredible.
They have been running at $100,000 a month,
$100,000 a month for the last three months in legal bills.
So they're now at a deficit of $20,000.
Personal audio has shown no signs of backing down from their litigation posture
despite a discovery process that has revealed the completely weak connection to
be drawn between their PR purported patent apparatus and dissemination of media
files that we do as podcasts are.
So what they're hoping for is that Adam somehow or another taps out.
And if he does,
then they try to hit everybody who podcast with,
you know,
hey,
give us 20 bucks a month or whatever the fuck it is.
Um,
so they're going to have to raise another 50,
oh 500,000 to $750,000 to continue with the litigation.
Unbelievable.
It's incredible.
It's sickening.
And the only thing is,
and,
and I don't know what it's like in Texas.
I know in New York it's hard to get,
but everyone thinks like,
well,
hey man,
I'll just try to get them to make them pay for my legal fees.
That doesn't always happen.
And,
and,
and it's a,
judges don't like to do that.
They don't like to give a,
I forget what it's called,
but it's when you make the,
uh,
the suing attorney with is suing the plaintiff,
pay the defendant's legal fees.
It has to be proven to be such a litigious I,
uh,
a frivolous thing.
So that's a really hard thing to do.
Yeah.
And if you want to help,
this is the way they've got it set up to help.
Um,
they have a,
uh,
podcast legal defense fund,
Amazon account.
And what that is,
is if buy something
from Amazon,
if you do it through that account,
they get a kickback.
They get a piece of the action.
So it doesn't cost you anything as a person.
So if you use Amazon a lot,
like I do,
I love to use Amazon.
If you use it,
please use it through the podcast,
legal defense,
Amazon Fund.
If you just Google that,
it's on fund anything.com you can,
um,
you can find the,
uh,
the,
the link to it and Adam has a video up there that explains what's going on and
how this all got started.
It's really gross.
It's,
it's,
and if you look at what the actual patented is itself,
it's crazy that they can sue for it.
It's essentially releasing things in a serialized form,
like a form one,
two,
three,
and four on the Internet.
I mean,
that's a list.
Yeah.
I mean that's like,
that's crazy.
Like the idea that you could patent that it's just fucking bananas.
Yeah,
it's,
and it's very,
I forget what it's called and they give them money.
It's really rare.
And they,
in London,
in England,
and fucking,
uh,
England,
I think they're much more likely to,
cause a lot of people are less likely to sue for something that's,
that they might be frivolous,
although they may not get it,
you may not be able to recover on a frivolous lawsuit because there may be legal
merits to this lawsuit.
Even if even if they lose,
what are the personal audio they're called?
They may,
it may not be a frivolous suit,
like in the legal system's eyes,
the legal system may see this as a legit suit that they win or lose as opposed
to a frivolous once Adam May not be able to get his money back,
even if he wins.
Do you know what I mean?
I totally hear you.
So even if he wins,
he might still be hit with all these legal fees.
Sure.
And of course whoever loses it can't be over of course,
unless pat.
Cause you know,
I'm guessing that the other place has more money than Adam does.
So an appeal will cost money and everyone who podcasts has a very,
very vested interest in this because I don't think it's a good lawsuit.
I mean I don't think that their right to ask for this at all.
I think it's bullshit of course.
And um,
these guys have already made a shit load of money suing apple.
They,
uh,
the,
they,
I think they made seven or 8 million,
8 million I think on the playlist or something.
And they were saying about a playlist hump.
Fucking crazy like that.
I have to piss badly.
Can I run in there?
Don't worry about it man.
So,
um,
anybody that wants to help just go to fund anything.com just Google podcast,
legal defense fund.
Um,
Amazon account.
Yeah,
you'll find it,
you'll find it and just try to do your Amazon shopping through there.
If everybody does that,
it will make a big difference and it'll be no hardship whatsoever for anybody,
you know,
that's,
that's helping to support the show.
Awesome.
On their fund.
Anything page.
They have a bunch of different packages,
you know,
like once 20 bucks,
once 40 bucks or whatever they got comes with a bunch of stuff.
So they want to like help out by using a package.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And Adam's a good guy and I'm glad he's doing this.
I'm glad he's not buckling and just,
I don't know why he got hit up and other people didn't get hit up.
You know,
you didn't get hit up.
No,
I got hit up.
I don't understand it.
You are you asking for money?
Because I think it has something to do with subscriptions are asking for money.
Did you ever ask for any money?
No.
I mean the only thing that we have at desk squad is just buying t shirts,
which I have been trying to keep a separate as from,
you
know,
totally separate.
Right.
That's just your tee shirts.
And if you want those folks,
go to get desk squad.tv.
If you see those cats and cat cats have flasks.
We have you wearing right now?
The one I have right now Capelle and flasks flasks so he can,
you can be one of those old timey drunks.
Put up a warm flask of whiskey in your back pocket as far gone it all day
according to your coffee or protect your chest pocket from bullets.
Yeah.
That doesn't happen upon occasion by the way.
Thanks for the the fanny pack.
I like it a lot.
She's like,
it's really,
and the first thing I thought of could I toyed with dice was dice would go nice
nuts for this and you're like,
yeah,
dynasties had something to do with it.
I'm like a dice got a roots fanny pack and he was wearing,
it was beautiful and I was like,
what'd you get that fanny pack or it go check it out.
And he gave it to me to check out and I ordered one from roots and then I
contacted roots and I had them design mind with the higher primary logo on it.
So good.
So I'm selling those fucking fanny packs.
The way to go.
People are scared of fanny packs.
Let me explain something to you.
A girl who will not fuck you because you're wearing a fanny pack was not going
to fuck you anyway.
Absolutely.
And if she was going to fuck you,
it wasn't going to be worth it.
It was going to be one of those where she fucks you.
She's like,
oh,
like what am I doing?
Plus I'm not,
I don't try to get laid in my fanny pack.
I don't,
I don't want to get a little club.
We're in a fucking fanny pack.
I wear it when I fly.
I like to fly comfortably and people are always like,
what are you wearing that for?
Cause I don't want to shit in my pockets.
That's why.
Sorry.
Let's close to look like the Fonz on a fucking plane.
There's like a baby.
I'm done.
Why am I doing the Fonz fucking,
you know what the fines is?
Why I try to be a fucking cool image on the plane.
It's like I'm flying,
I'm,
I'm right from the airport right now.
I'm wearing my oversize Ozzie shirt,
my sweat pants.
It's like that.
You fly to be comfortable and that's such an easy thing to do.
You take that thing off,
put it in the tray that goes through,
you're done,
clip it back on.
You don't have to empty your pockets out.
It doesn't include as one of your carry ons either when you have it around your
weight,
so if you have like a backpack and a suitcase,
you can also have a fanny pack attached to your body so it doesn't count as not
true.
No.
Does certain comments really?
I had a woman tell me that I had to take it off and I put it in my back.
I'm like,
are you serious?
I go,
what's the difference between this and the pocket?
She goes,
it's a bag,
sir.
You have to have your bag inside another bag or you're going to have to check.
It should just be in a con.
She of course she was and I was like,
oh Jesus,
fucking Christ.
But you can't say you're being a con because that's a really,
that's the little Chella plane.
She was conti.
She of course she was.
So I just opened up my backpack.
It's stuffed it in there.
But I was like,
this is the dumbest fucking shit ever.
Like he said her,
I'm sitting by the way in my seat when she said this to me.
Wait,
you on the plane?
Yes.
On the plane.
Sitting in my seat with my belt buckled the whole deal.
So I had to take off the fanny pack and put it in my fucking backpack.
The one,
one time only for this one chick that just decided that's ridiculous.
You know,
that's what happens man.
You run into the wrong person.
What is it that a major airline or was it a,
a subsidiary,
like a smaller,
like,
you know,
you have your Delta,
you have delta,
but was it a big plan or a small plan?
Okay.
Cause a lot of times the ones on this,
like you had continental,
the continental express,
United,
United Express and the United expressing Cottonelle expressed there are other
airlines or American Eagle that's not American Airlines.
There are a smaller airline operating with the American logo.
So there are totally separate airline.
So what will happen is,
uh,
you know,
they,
they to me on the smaller planes are fucking worst with the regulations.
Headphones out please.
Like whether you were listening to music or not.
And it never happened to me on a big plane.
It was always those little American Eagle,
United Express,
continental express or whatever.
The delta was weird cause you're not operating,
they are operating some equipment.
It's like a Corgan express.
Whoever the fuck it's called is the actual airline.
They use United paint and United ticketing,
but they're operating kind of as a courier service for United or whoever the
when they are.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
It's,
it's gotta be a tough Gig to be a flight attendant.
Sure.
But she,
that's just creating issues.
There's no need to do that.
I'm,
I'm friendly if you're with me.
I've never get an initial,
I mean,
I even argue with her,
I said,
really,
I got to take this off.
And she goes,
yes sir.
That's about it.
I'm like,
all right,
just put it in my bag.
I'm done.
You know,
I'm not,
I don't,
yeah,
I don't need to.
But that's just creating an issue for no reason.
I saw a man and another man getting a mild dispute about something and this
woman who was the flight attendant treated bolted them like they were fucking
children and just rode it into the ground,
didn't let it go.
Brought out the pilot,
made the pilot,
talked to both men.
Totally unnecessary.
What were they disputing though?
There would be disputing overhead space and this is what happened.
Um,
a guy had more than one thing in an overhead and another guy went to put
something in.
He like opened up the thing and there was no space in there.
And I think you said something like,
you know,
you've got,
why do you have two things in there?
And the guy said,
hey,
first come first serve.
And the other guy says bull shit.
And he sits down,
that's it.
The one guy,
he's got two bags,
he puts it in there and he goes,
there's no,
there's no room for other people.
It goes,
Hey,
first come,
first serve.
They got a guy,
he goes bull shit.
And he sits down.
That's the whole dispute.
The woman wouldn't let the guy have a drink.
The guy asked for a drink.
She goes,
no,
you're not going to have a drink if I decide to let you have a drink later,
I'll let you have a drink.
She brought out the f,
the,
uh,
pilots and she even talked to me.
She was like,
if things go crazy,
you know,
if either one of these guys gets out of line,
I'm looking to you to,
to take care of this.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
all these fucking,
these guys aren't,
no one's getting out of,
you're creating something out of nothing.
But she kept harping on him and pestering.
You know how there's some people that if they get in an argument about
something,
like whatever it is,
if they,
they,
there's something that winds them up.
Even if it's minor,
they will beat it into the ground until it becomes major.
They'll just ride you,
ride your ride,
you until you,
what could you shut the fuck up?
It's almost like she was trying to get these guys to blow up so she could
justify her,
whatever internal strife,
her internal anger that she was projecting onto the situation,
but I saw the whole thing go down.
It was so minor.
Either that or she was on a flight,
ones were too drunk,
began arguing and the flight got diverted and then she was late.
She was supposed to meet a guy with a huge Dick and she missed it because their
plane had to land in De Moines.
I like your story better because my story,
she's just fucking measly.
Cut My story.
She was fucking on her way to get some giant Dick and she didn't want either one
of these fucking petty zilch is to interfere.
It was just was the way she talked to them.
It was like she had a green light.
Sure.
To say what she wanted it and push the issue is hard.
They really do.
And look,
I mean after nine 11 we all change that.
We saw flying and we got to give them a lot of leeway.
But it does get to be a point where you have to be able to go like,
look,
you're being a fucking complete and utter twat.
Right.
But you can never say that anymore ever.
I do look at situations very differently.
If I see people getting into dispute on an airplane,
I,
I do look at it like as a potential.
I mean,
I don't look at it as like a terrorist situation,
but I do look at it as a potential like,
whoa,
you know,
people do bad shit to each other.
Sometimes bad shit can go down.
Sure.
And people are still allowed to carry a lot of fucking dangerous shit on planes.
They took away pool cues and they took away knives and a few things and they
were going to bring back pocket knives and pool cues,
but then they changed it because,
uh,
what happened?
Someone did something,
oh,
that guy showed up in lax and shot a bunch of TSA workers.
Remember that he killed that one TSA worker,
that Guy May,
they pulled back this regulation change that they were going to have because of
this guy.
But people still bring skateboards on.
You could fuck somebody up on a scale Mac book pro,
even that Shit's fucking titanium or just let it get it all or close it while
it's still on.
Cause they always heat up and then say to somebody,
hold us down.
I'm like,
ah,
I'm struggle.
I'm really passive way to beat somebody up.
Yeah.
Especially if you rubbed the bottom of it and get it all friction knee rubbing
on them and watch them get shocked and burn.
But yeah,
the,
the idea of a violence on a plane just freaks a lot of people out.
And again,
the diversion of the flight,
we've seen too many videos of guys yelling and screaming or that one fucking buy
Polak cut wherever they're from trying to open the door.
Oh yeah.
I think a big part of it,
and we've seen so much more than the last 20 something years because there's no
more smoking on planes and I'm glad.
But I think a lot of what you see in rageful situations is people jonesing for
cigarettes.
Because there were times where I couldn't have a cigarette.
Best thing I would do is quit smoking in 2001 but when I'd be on a flight,
if we were going to move,
when I was opening for dice,
we're going to Dallas.
It said it was an hour delay of,
fuck,
that's another hour.
I can't smoke.
And you start your body,
you start to feel that fucking,
that withdrawal.
And a lot of people are probably going through that on planes and freaking out
that they can't smoke.
Oh,
I guarantee and I'm glad they can't smell it,
but I think that's a part of,
and then it'll get the fucking petty do.
She's not even letting you have the fake.
Some of the fake cigarettes do smell.
Kurt Metzger,
uh,
who's a good friend of mine was writing for the show that I'm doing with smoke.
These fucking things in the editing bay.
They smelled like vanilla bark and they are nowhere near as offensive as a real
cigarette.
But it was still like was like a sweet ass hole wafting.
It was like the fuck you doing.
He had one that was smoking in here for why it was strawberry.
Eh,
well the,
you know,
the thing I'm reading about those is they don't know if that shit safe cause
you're breathing something.
It's not vapor.
You breathing something that has something in it,
you know?
And there's no studies that have been done on it.
There's no studies about the secondhand smoke and whatever it is.
It's,
it's also you're making someone breathe your smell.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's like if you were spraying perfume in the area,
I'd be like,
come on fuck head.
Why he's spraying perfume.
Making people aware of your scent.
Like wearing perfume.
Yeah.
Women don't know how to wear perfume.
Right.
Some do.
Most of them.
You're generalizing that crazy.
Yeah.
I mean you can go anywhere where there's women in smell perfume.
If you focus in on it,
you know,
like why am I smelling having to smell this?
I was in a restaurant recently and some guy had one of those big ass vapor
pipes.
I mean,
it was like a big fat tube one that he was puffing on and the fucking,
it was filling the restaurant with smart.
Right.
But because it's like a vapor pipe or whatever the fuck it's supposed to be and
not lighting a fire,
it's supposedly okay.
But I'm like,
this is crazy.
Because I was eating with my kids and I was like,
we're sitting here in this guy smoke.
Right.
It was a lot of it.
I mean,
he was taking these and you could see it.
It wasn't like those blue cigarettes,
you know those things,
those sharia blue e-cigs.
When you blow those out,
it's like it's up and it's gone in seconds.
It doesn't have any smell this.
That's kind of what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
Those are the ones that are okay.
But those,
those fat ones that are like,
they're all different in their delivery method.
They're all different.
And the,
the,
the way they burn the oils and tobacco oil,
some of them it's fucking smoke.
It's smoke.
I mean,
you're just,
you're burning oil instead of burning plant matter.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
Yes.
Smokeless ones.
Now though.
Awesome.
Those,
you know,
those you can't argue with.
And also gum nicotine gum I guess is great.
He never helped me when other smell go try it on planes.
It tastes like pepper.
I didn't never did anything for me.
It makes me want to puke.
Almost Marin addicted to those.
Yeah.
A lot of such rich Veloce.
This is how awful rich vos has is a human.
He'll fucking come in studio and he'll be with chewing them in mid story and
then he'll talk one up under his,
God,
you've had Boston here.
Oh and he'll eat that while one is under his gums heal.
Oh fucking God.
He'll eat a tuna fish sandwich salad.
The way he would say it to
or,
or you know,
or fucking,
you know,
white fish whenever awful food he'll eat.
White fish is fucking thing tucked up under,
you know,
verses a weird guy.
Very.
And he's one of my face.
He's really one of the most underrated funny people.
He's very funny and he's funny.
Off the cuff,
more so than it eve is on stage lightning.
This is a joke that we'd been quoting.
We had Pete rose in the other day.
I listen.
How did you hear that?
And the lightens the line he had.
That was,
it was so fast.
It was,
it was almost depressing.
Whereas a,
I think Pete Rose said to Voss,
he goes,
uh hey,
you're a little,
when Bob Kelly was in and he goes,
you're a little winded.
Waskow's that's cause I had to walk around you and Bobby like that fast.
It was was,
it was like he had been
waiting for someone to say Voss,
you seem winded.
Yeah.
So just when you want to just take a fucking a pick ax and hit rich in the
chest,
he reminds you of his comedic brilliance.
Like he'll do something like to have the gun with the white fish and you hate
him.
But then as I said,
something that's so comedically brilliant,
like this guy,
there's a genius to rich Voss.
I love how you guys had just gotten done talking about how no is going to sit in
Anthony seed.
You should probably put a glass box around it.
Boss comes in the room and the first thing he does is sit in,
they have to be seated.
He goes,
I never really liked that guy anyway.
He's just a fucking Asberger's funny guy.
Like that's what Voss is.
He's completely,
he'll make fun of anybody.
He'll make fun of anything.
Like he kinda does a purity to rich [inaudible] he's fucking be just turned 57.
Yeah.
Wow.
He's really up there and he's childish and uh,
he's petty.
How old is this kid?
He's got a few.
He's got three is his daughter.
Rain I think is six or so with Bonnie or five.
And there's other kids are like in college when he was 52.
Yeah.
Wow.
And is that the kids are grown.
They're like college age girls.
Wow.
And uh,
have you ever listened to their podcast?
I have.
I did it once.
I did the,
uh,
I was,
the guest is painful.
I think bill burrs doing it in Montreal where my wife hates me,
so brutal,
so brutal.
And she's so much faster than him.
She's so smart.
But it's so funny to listen.
Nobody has a better sense of humor about each other as a couple.
Like I've seen them brutalize each other,
like the things that would destroy me as a,
as a member of a couple.
And they just laugh it off and they're fine.
I can't believe it for like two goldfish.
Like they just forget the hatred they spewed at each other.
And the,
yeah,
my wife,
there's so funny together.
It's like gimme that's the relationship the two comedians should have.
And I could never have one.
Well,
it'd be a great reality show.
Um,
I'm amazing.
They don't have,
because the business stinks.
That's why our show business stinks that they haven't taken fucking rich and
Bonnie,
um,
these,
these two fucker presented anywhere a million times and they're good at pitching
shows and Bonnie is really good at it.
And they're funny.
And the meetings,
uh,
I don't know why they haven't,
maybe because they don't,
uh,
I dunno.
I was just saying maybe they don't want that.
I couldn't even think of a followup resign.
He's,
the only thing that I could think of is that shows with comedians.
I mean,
how many reality shows with comedians have there been Tammy Pesky tell you how
to show for a while.
Remember that and I do not.
Um,
who else has anybody mean last comic standing?
It's kind of a reality because comedians are to Pauly shore killed the whole
fucking genre or is it because comics are actually concise,
funny and not situational like or comedians are not goofy situation.
Funny like all doesn't realize she's putting pepper on her oatmeal,
you know,
like,
like you know,
every dump cut in a reality show does something stupid.
I'm going to look for a walk.
[inaudible] but home it's upside down.
Six,
seven car.
My keys.
You're holding him.
Oh yeah.
And comics would just dissect comics or two in the moment.
This is how dumb we are as comedians will say like,
you know,
hey,
what do you want me to do?
There's a guy with a camera looking at me.
Why?
You know,
we acknowledged too much.
Right?
I did family jewels,
I roasted gene and then they wanted me to do this kind of like pseudo reality
thing at the end with gene and his wife.
And and someone else,
but of course like a Douche.
I referenced the camera guy and be like,
yeah,
you're not supposed to mention that he's here.
Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe we're too,
we don't know how to shut the fuck up.
I Love Gene Simmons.
I can't watch that show.
It's just so God damn.
Fuck.
I love him too.
I love him.
I can't watch this.
I would saw him the other day.
He was at the glory kickboxing fights in La.
It was fucking awesome to see him again.
Yeah,
but however I can't watch,
I did sit so much fuckery in those shows.
There's no reality shows.
Every reality show has these fixed scenarios and they're faking shit that like
you would never think they fake.
Like there's certain,
like they were talking about those storage wars shows,
you know,
they just fill those storage's.
They fill them.
They set it all up.
It's all fake.
But no one know.
Open the door.
We don't even know what's in there.
What's an a typewriter?
You fucking put it there.
They put the,
they put everything in those boxes.
It's all fake.
You're hoping that they opened one from fucking,
uh,
from Hannibal lectors.
One of his clients.
Nice Limo with a fucking head in the jar.
That'd be,
that'd be a critic.
Hester Moffitt.
You're hoping it's one of those,
but yeah,
you're right.
It's all fixed and the only real one was the Osborne.
Sharon said there was no take two ever.
They have to,
because it was nine months of filming.
They don't want to commit to that kind of filming.
They don't want to take the time it would take because I think that my life is
fascinating and like,
wow.
But I look at my life,
I'm like,
all right.
Episodic reality show.
Jim Norton.
I wake up,
I go do the radio,
I come hall,
I go to the gym.
There's nothing there.
Maybe a couple of funny lines on the radio and me and the gym.
I'm tired again.
All right,
there's a minute of the show kill.
Here's the real show.
You getting prostitutes.
I thought of that.
I've tried to pitch that to vice and they didn't want it.
I'm like,
I want to go look.
Here's the thing,
like I go from fucking place to place in brothels.
I give you reviews and they're just like,
no one,
they said no.
Well like what's entertaining about finding like me getting blow jobs,
everything,
but they won't show the blow jobs and the hookers probably wouldn't sign up for
it cause they don't have to have a big blurry thing over everybody's head.
I,
here's what I want it to do.
This was my idea for a reality segment.
I really want it to do this with massage girls because I fucking like,
like I'm drinking this any type of milk product.
I'm fucking a horrible farter and I really wanted to take a hidden camera and
have massage girls come over and just somehow like signal the camera when I'm
going to cut a gasser like,
like I'll say beforehand,
every time I say the word yellow,
it means I'm about to Fart so that you'll,
you'll see me on there and I'll go like,
you know,
like yeah,
something,
something yellow and then I'll fart maybe quietly and then you can watch her
react.
But the problem is you can't show the face.
And,
and too many of them would say no to that,
but that's what I wanted to do.
But how am I,
how long would that be interesting Jim farts during massages.
Yeah,
but you say that people
wouldn't,
like you couldn't go to brothels,
but you could if the girls were porn stars.
That's true.
That is true.
And I would do that.
I would love to do that.
But then I'm like Collin Quinn a long time ago,
remind me many,
many years.
My first,
I go on an opiate addict.
I was dating a British girl and she was a real pervert.
Like I drove a Saturn back then.
I still lived in Jersey and I used to fucking park outside of Dangerfield and
she would blow me.
I would trap.
She liked been to trap her head under my steering wheel and she'd go like,
I want you to bite me.
Like she would repeat this mantra of me biting her on her back.
But she liked to be bitten and brutalized.
Wow.
So would bite her back and she'd be like,
I want you to make me suck it.
And then I would hold her head under the wheel and she'll be trapped under my
Saturday steering wheel
and fucking,
she would suck my dick and lick my balls and whatever could kid.
She was a good girl.
Yeah.
Her name is Ruth.
She was a really cool girl.
Ruth.
Yeah.
Good five and talked to her in 15 years.
But she was a great girl.
I miss her terribly.
I think she went back across the pond.
Hello?
As they say.
And what was the point of this story?
Oh,
Collin College,
she was really loud when I ate her pussy.
Really super loud and it was say,
I don't remember.
It's just moaning and groaning.
Gb One of those things.
Yeah,
yeah,
the,
yeah.
He said whatever it was.
Ooh,
look,
I with my,
my pussy,
like it's Manchester United,
you know what I'm saying?
But I can't,
it was a really loud and it puts you a sloppy fucking wet.
Like it was legit.
Like I knew she wasn't putting on a show cause her pussy was sloppy.
But I was going to eat her pussy on the air opiate.
This is before I was there,
like a every day and it will be,
it's said quality and your pussy on the air.
And I was going to do that and Colin Quinn stopped me and he goes,
ah,
you know,
and he goes,
you can do that.
He goes,
but man,
you're a comic.
You got to say funny shit.
You don't want to be that guy that does wacky things.
And I'm like,
I never forgot that.
He was almost telling me,
don't be a stunt boy.
You gotta say it funny.
You got to sit there and be funny verbally and I maybe in that case he was right
because I wasn't the guy,
the Wacko who called up at eight pussy on the air.
It's like I have to be able to be funny in my delivery and say,
and I was like,
eh.
It was kind of a good point.
I'm looking back in hindsight,
I probably should have eaten her pussy on the arcs.
It'd be a very funny clip.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying though.
I know what he was saying.
Yeah.
You can get stuck in that trap of being the stunt guy,
having a one up yourself every time.
Like,
oh no,
Jim Norton did this crazy thing.
He put his ass hole,
his finger in his ass.
It's like,
yeah,
I'd rather be the guy that talks about it then the guy that actually
demonstrates it and gets the laugh.
Cause then if I talk about it,
people like us not,
it's funny.
Yeah.
Isn't that a weird thing where people get trapped in that stunk guide thing?
Like there's a lot of those stunt guys that are on radio shows.
Like there was a radio show that I did where they made this guy dress up like a
cow and it's rollerskate and jump over a chair.
And if he didn't jump over that he didn't make over the chairs.
So they had to punish them.
And so,
uh,
like,
and he was like,
you just,
whatever punishment they had and the punishment was,
uh,
I,
I choked him unconscious.
Oh God.
And I go,
you sure you want to do this?
He's like,
I got to do whatever they tell me to do.
I go,
really?
It was like so weird.
I was like,
this is a local radio show.
Like,
like you really have to do this.
But he was like,
like he was like a slave like in sort of like we'll do,
I will do it.
Master tells me to,
I will do what they tell me to do.
So I choke them unconscious a slave for the recognition of the radio.
She just sat there and I put my arms around and I go,
well let me know when you're gonna tap out.
Like if you have,
you can't take it anymore,
just tap out and I'll let you go.
You Ready?
And he's like,
yeah.
And I just squeeze them out.
And the weird thing is,
good luck doing that on a regular radio again.
That's probably a while,
dude.
No Way.
One lawsuit,
one person dies drinking water.
You know,
you're lucky you get a fucking a bottle of water in the studio now cause they
all panic.
Can you let in some guy collapsed your fucking wind pipe?
You know,
like I know how to do it,
but what if I didn't know how to do it?
What if I heard them and you know,
you the UFC sent out a memo or they told us,
I forgot what it was.
Well,
there's official or nonofficial with a few years back,
two people got sued for taking photos with people where they were choking him in
the picture as a joke.
Oh my.
Matt Hughes got sued and Chuck Ladell got sued.
Both frivolous lawsuits.
Where a guy,
I get it all the time,
guys either say,
can I choke you out in a picture?
Which I say no.
And then they say,
well,
can you choke me out in the picture?
Like one of those two always comes up.
Yeah.
And the uh,
what,
what that but that to me like what a piece of shit move that is?
Well,
one of the guys was a bad cop.
One of the guys that,
the Matt Hughes Guy,
they investigated him,
turned out the dude was like doing something drug related,
something dirty,
wound up going to jail.
I'll really,
yeah,
because of that,
because of the investigation that started from him suing Matt.
He goes,
Matt Hughes,
you know,
the guy says,
let me,
uh,
we take a picture of choking me.
So he's choking the guy and the guy's going to like that and takes a picture
that it takes that photograph and says,
Hey,
Matt Hughes choked me.
I want to get some money.
Same thing with chuck.
I think chuck actually wound up,
I don't know if you want to paint him,
but there was a,
it was a real situation.
I always asked him,
his guys to do things.
I haven't done it in a while whenever they're in studio,
but it was on video,
so there was the context of me asking,
I guess.
No,
it was obvious it was a,
and it would,
and you tapped out and it was like,
I just want to feel it,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
You did it with fade or I've had fatal or has choked me and punch me.
He enjoyed it because he punched me hard and then he was choking me and I was
like,
all right,
I tap,
tap,
tap.
And he did it again and he smiled and he did it again.
Like he's a fucking,
he's a really brutal Russian.
Yeah.
Uh,
the Alaska is choked me.
I think it was a gay teen choke standing 18,
I think.
Uh,
brutal.
I mean,
Rhonda fucking arm barred me.
Um,
I never did anything with Lidl.
Rampage funny cause they were before Silva kicked me.
Ah,
Jon Jones hurt me the worst.
He fucking,
John Jones put his knee in my uh,
heat.
Jon Jones,
his thing,
he's punched me before chuck me fucking Uriah.
Maybe it's stopped.
They've all injured me.
Jon Jones putting that fucking Shin
in my thigh like a or,
or a need of the thought.
Whatever he did,
it hurts so badly.
I almost vomited on the floor.
Who's Randy couture did it too.
Yeah.
And sound.
Patrice was in studio that day and he said to Randy,
pretend use the same technique you would use if you were choking out a clam
clam.
Yeah,
you really smashed me.
But,
uh,
there was one a year Jones hitting me with the,
the,
that's the one right there where he's choking me now.
All right.
You Ready?
Okay.
Here.
All right.
Here we go.
That's something else too.
We're looking at fats,
Ohio.
He does something else where he puts his shin in my fucking leg.
Did he kick you or did he just,
it was kind of like a,
I don't know.
You'll know if we can fast forward to it.
You'll know what it is if you see it.
It was so shocking to my system.
I almost threw up on the console.
It was,
it was a,
I almost fainted.
I actually walked out of the fuck.
That's five different times I went to the bathroom,
threw water on my face.
Whoa.
Because it was like,
it was like my whole system overloaded,
like,
and he bullied me.
He could've,
it was,
you know,
it was 20% of his strength.
Yeah.
If that,
but he was,
it was fight week.
Never do that shit there and fight with a,
they're ornery and be there in fucking combat mode.
That was a dumb time to do it.
Like you know the first sit right here.
I don't want to be combative with my hands.
That's,
that sounds good
right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
No,
that's good to hear you.
Yeah.
Chantal leg kick.
That was essentially the weight of his Shin and his leg and he puts something
into it,
but not enough to do any type of real damage.
It was just where it was.
I couldn't believe I reacted that way.
Like my system was like,
you'll get lightheaded,
tingly feeling.
You get like,
I'm going to vomit,
I'm going to vomit.
And then I was like,
I'm going to pass out.
I had to go to the bathroom,
put water on my face,
like a fucking like an old lady.
But that's a,
that's a really painful technique.
This is certainly is.
It doesn't,
it's a weird thing because those guys,
they're so used to fighting off of pain and dealing with the pain and the
adrenaline of the fight that a lot of people underestimate the impact of leg
kicks.
I've,
I've learned like,
you know,
everyone knows you have,
see hearts in mixed martial arts is painful,
but after doing that I've been like,
it makes you watch the sport differently.
Like,
like to watch,
like I'll watch it.
I,
my favorite fighters are those fucking Brazilian,
like you know those leg kickers,
man.
I know it's fucking Josie aldose or by both of those guys that are like,
we like flaps.
Oh yeah.
Because after experiencing that,
I'm like the fact that guy can stand there and still fight after having his leg
like that,
it never ceases to amaze me that they don't immediately collapsed and just go
home.
Well,
they don't feel it as much because of the adrenaline of the fight,
but it is unbelievably painful even with the adrenaline.
And then after it's over.
Like did you have ever received a Uriah where his whole leg after he fought Aldo
was swollen to twice the size of his other leg.
He took all these photos of it and posted them on Twitter.
Like as it was healing,
it was just a giant purple sausage.
It was crazy.
Or you see the leg kicks that knocked the guy's leg back.
Like when the guy standing on that leg kick.
That's sweet.
Like if you kick a guy's leg hard enough to sweep it back where he's almost off
balance.
Like man,
that's a really hard how chihuahua kick and when still the kicked me,
I kept trying to get in to kick a little harder because he was going so gently.
He's a nice guy.
He's a very nice and okay.
Yeah,
he's such a meek like pleasant fellow a and then he just,
he kicked me slightly harder and it just jarred my head when he kicked me in the
arm and I had a headache for two hours because of my head jarred and I wasn't
ready for,
you know.
Yeah.
Well that's you know,
one of the places where concussions take place,
like everyone thinks a concussion is when you get hit in the head,
but there's doctors explained it to me that a concussion is anything that
happens from your chest up.
Like you can get like hit really hard in a football match.
You can get hit really hard like in the chest and the game and you get a
concussion because the impact that makes your head around your brain sloshes
around inside your skull and you get a concussion from that so you don't even
have to get hit in the head.
They get a concussion.
Yeah,
it's,
it's every one of those moves hurt a lot.
And when you feel the grip that a guy like that puts on you like again like a
cane is a fucking monster,
but any anyone who puts a grip on you and it's like it,
it is simply an unbreakable situation.
I'm in like I am only alive and not fucked in the ass because he's choosing not
to do those things.
It's a really weird feeling to be.
It makes you like maybe the older you get,
the more aware you are,
the bad shit can happen.
But it makes you very cautious in life.
Like these are the guys that are walking around and like you try not to start
confrontations with people for no reason cause you don't know who has a pistol.
That woman who was assaulted,
Anthony had no idea that he's a guy with a gun and lucky for her,
he's not a maniac with a gun.
She had talk her on Twitter.
What if he just got a really good leg kick that when you decided I'm not going
to punch abroad but while whack.
Yeah.
But then,
but then they would have said he struck a woman and then he would have been even
probably more fuck cause they're an illegal proceedings.
You know,
she would have said that this just showed the gun very illegal.
Very illegal.
Yes.
Especially when you look like fucking,
yeah.
You can't just show it.
Yeah.
It's supposed to do that.
First of all,
it looks like chef from apocalypse now.
Nobody wanted him to be flashing at.
Joey Cola told me that he was working at pips and in Brooklyn and some guy in
the front row was heckling him and showing him his gun.
He's so fucking busy.
She fucking piece of shit.
You fucking terrible saying all this crazy shit to him.
And he goes and I'm upset.
I just gotta keep going.
My jokes,
I'm update telling my jokes,
you know,
Joey Cola,
nicest guy in the world and he's,
he's onstage and
this guy keeps brandishing.
It got his pips even around anymore for signing around anymore.
I just talked to a guy the other night,
he used to own pibs I forget.
He's like,
yeah,
we always trying to get you in there.
I,
I did it when the Shults has had it.
And then I think Ray Garvey,
we took over and read ray died.
He had stomach cancer.
Did you know ray or no,
I never worked there.
I did a few spots there.
I never worked there either.
I probably went there with auto one time and you know,
or would it be because dice was already long gone dice used to do that place.
A lot of ways from Dangerfield,
all those guys from pips.
But uh,
George Schultz had it.
Seth Schultz,
um,
you know,
I know when Marty and,
uh,
I think Marnie and Seth had it when I did it.
Dangerfield still around.
It is still going strong.
I haven't done it in a long time.
I used to do that,
that that was one of the ones that helped me work on my,
my shit because you got 25 minutes to go up and I would put some notes on the
piano.
There's that black piano,
it's a block.
It reminds me of the comedy store and you'd go up and there's a history there
and just do your shit.
And um,
I worked out a lot of fucking material.
I paid my rent when I lived with Jim Florentine in North Jersey.
I would do seven spots on a Saturday,
a Saturday and six on a Friday.
And I would do Dangerfield,
seller Dangerfield,
seller from fucking first avenue and 60th to western and Mcdougal.
And I drove out of the park,
my stupid fucking Saturn.
And uh,
you,
you knew where to park and you know,
it was a whole system I got into,
but danger fields really helped me develop as a comic.
Did she ever do the Prom shows there?
Yes I did.
They're horrible.
But you were making 75 is set.
And I was like,
okay.
And you did a lot of sets.
How many cents?
What we do at night.
Sometimes you do,
it depends on how many fucking awful,
uh,
teenagers were coming in.
But sometimes it'd be three or four a night.
You can make an extra 300 bucks or sometimes just one way.
One of the most painful promise shows ever is,
I did Caroline's years ago and I did a pro set and Willie Tyler and Leicester
were on the show and you know,
I knew them from,
you know,
solid goals to shows it very nice guy.
I had a,
one of the best ventriloquists ever and he's on stage and it was just not for
the kids and material,
you know,
it was a little like he's,
and he's doing some song and I believe I can fly and on the fucking puppet sing
and it's a fun song and these kids from the Bronx,
we're just not enjoying it.
It was ugly fly home motherfucker,
you suck.
Oh,
it was horrible.
I've net and he smiled and kept it professional and didn't acknowledge any of
it.
He that talked about take your money and get out.
That's what he did.
Do you remember Al Lubell?
Sure I do.
I live well.
I need a giant cock.
That's what I remember about Al Labelle.
I've heard he had a big cock.
Yeah.
Al Lubell was on stage.
We're doing prom shows,
a danger fields and a kid got onstage is big football player.
Kid came onstage,
took the microphone from Bell and Blue Cigar,
smoke in his face,
had a cigar and he was standing on on stage and all his friends were cheering
and no one did anything about it.
And I was like,
wow,
that's why I stopped working there.
Not because it didn't happen to me,
but they wouldn't.
I didn't feel they took,
they didn't protect the comics enough from hecklers.
Like they would never call,
throw people out and that's why I stopped working there.
Well,
it's very much like the comedy store in that way.
Both old sort of dark places in both with no crowd control.
They had
one guy.
Do you remember Bobby all?
I met Bobby one time.
Bobby would take care of shit.
I worked with Bobby a lot.
He was a Scottish guy who was about five foot eight wide and five foot eight
tall.
He was a fucking tank,
this guy,
but he wasn't fat.
Right.
He was like,
oh,
well,
you know,
he wasn't the skinniest guy in the world,
but he was a power lifter and he was strong as fuck and something happened.
I forgot what it was,
but I saw him pick a guy up by his neck.
He literally grabbed this guy by the back of his neck and picked him up like a
kitten.
Like he had his hand on this guy's neck,
hoisted him up out of his chair,
grabbed his belt and just carried them out.
And the guy just went limp,
like feeling how strong Bobby was.
He's just like,
fuck this.
He just completely went limp and Bobby carried him outside and tossed them.
Yeah,
he's a legendary guy.
Bobby.
Uh,
everyone loved him.
Whatever happened to that guy.
He died.
Oh,
he's got a long time ago.
Yeah,
he died many years ago,
I think.
I don't know,
actually.
He was out.
I think Tony's son Tony,
who ran it with Rodney,
his son took over for a while and I haven't seen his son down in many years
either,
but he was the guy.
I kind of got to know you.
I knew Darren was Darren and Bobby.
I only met once when I went in there with somebody.
Oh,
that sucks that that guy died.
Yeah,
man,
I heard that.
I never got to know him and I kind of wish I did.
He was such
vibrant character.
I can't believe he died.
Well,
I know him and the kid,
him and Darren had a falling out.
Right.
The kid,
right.
That was what he called it,
right?
Yeah.
The Kid,
the bug of Shite.
Everything was up.
I got shaken.
I know.
Talent back.
I shake it up there that you're tricked them again.
The Rogan,
like every time we go home,
if I had a good laughs,
he would say,
oh,
you tricked them again.
Good comedians say there's funnier than any of the comics too.
It's very funny.
He was very,
very funny.
He was a hilarious guy.
I enjoyed that guy very much.
I would go there and looking forward to seeing them.
I'm bummed that I never got to work.
The old catch either with Louis friend who was there.
I went in there a couple of times.
I might have done one set there,
but I never worked there.
The catch on Second Avenue,
this is my first set I ever did in New York.
Yeah,
I did.
When I was auditioning for Sossman,
I did some sets in Boston.
Then he outed me,
come out to New York and audition out there in the first set I ever did in New
York.
I was fucking terrified out of my mind was that catch I w I got there early.
I drove down from Boston,
wandered around the neighborhood shitting my pants,
terrified.
I just,
I always had this thing in my head about doing standup in New York for whatever
reason.
I just thought that New York was harder.
The people were smarter.
When I got on stage,
I realized they were just people you know,
but the,
but up until that moment,
I was like,
they're living in the city.
These are people that live in this city.
You know,
in New York City it has this air about it.
This is very intimidating air
because you know,
comedians,
they think like while New York's a big city,
if you worked at your s there's this illusion or this diluted nature,
you'll have the people,
the communities in New York are smarter.
Some of them are like,
you know,
you get a talent,
Collin who are geniuses and they get,
but you have plenty of Shitty Haqqanis,
plenty of dumb audiences.
Plenty of fucking,
I mean the comedy cellar is my home and it's my favorite place in the world and
you'll still have a bachelorette party.
I was on stage
maybe a few months ago,
killing on a Saturday.
Like really one of those sets that you just fucking hammering and right before I
get off these fucking middle age bachelorettes one of them go say something
funny.
It's just a matter where you are.
No matter how good your show is,
you know there's always that element.
Thank God I was killing.
I really brutalized her.
It was all I couldn't,
I couldn't have said cunt faster.
If I had been,
if I had been programmed to say at that moment it flew out so naturally and
beautifully,
which during a bad set is a bad thing because then the crowd totally agrees with
the person.
But in that moment that you know,
is there anything better than calling someone a cunt and fucking crowd cheers.
Oh yeah.
The angry Bachelorette party attendance.
Do you record your sets?
I do.
Everyone I videotape on a little,
uh,
on a little lot of Gopro.
You videotape them all?
Well,
yeah.
Just because I'm more creative when I do that.
Cause I know like if I want to Improv on something I will because I'm taping it
so I know I'll have it.
I record everything.
Audio,
I just use my iPhone,
I put it on.
Okay,
sure I have all.
But it is good to see yourself too and well,
it's also easier to go forward.
I could zip through it a little bit easier and uh,
you know,
we're stuffy or they know where stuff is and my iPhone,
like I don't trust that being out.
That's got to stay in the pocket because it's just too much shit on there that
it cannot be lost too many and explicable photos.
But the NSA has your photos.
Let them have them.
Then they're not buying tickets to see me.
You've seen that fucking new revelation that came out today that Edward Snowden
was saying that they were passing,
the NSA guys were passing back and forth naked photographs.
I heard it got through searches.
They would also do searches on their girlfriends and,
and uh,
you know,
cause they had access.
Wow.
Yeah.
So they'd find compromising photos and they would share them with each other.
They would send them like send this one.
The Tom and Tom would send that one to Billy liquid.
Bobby found,
you know,
and these people that they were investigating,
naked terrorist shots,
some chicken,
a burger with a big hairy beaver.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't,
you know,
it's funny,
my views on the NSA is as bad as they are.
We at,
that's what we deserve with a nosiest fucking culture.
All we do is,
is mind everybody's business.
There's nothing an American loves more than a stick off fucking face in
somebody's privacy.
And it made me so happy when that shit happened because it was like,
good,
you mother fuckers.
Where were you all of these years defending people's right to be assholes in
private.
We're voyeurs,
we love it.
And not when it's turned on us,
we don't like it.
Did you see the newest one about the British spies manipulating polls?
Yes.
Online polls and youtube hits and videos.
Yeah.
I mean it's literally everything that Alex Jones has been saying for years.
Everybody's been calling him crazy.
He's vindicated.
I mean,
he's been saying that the propaganda machine,
but they're really,
they are,
they're using government propaganda and all sorts of hacking tools.
It's really a fascinating thing.
A collection of hacking,
some of
which are specifically suited for spreading disinformation were exposed.
An elite 2012 document provided by stolen to the intercept is the online
publication led by Greg Glenn Greenwald,
the journalist's blah,
blah,
blah.
So I mean,
they,
uh,
underpass,
a tool that lets government changed the outcome of online polls.
They can change the outcome of online polls,
a bomb bay,
it can increase website hits and rankings so they can increase website hits,
change online amplifications of given for propaganda APP,
amplification of a given message.
Normally video on a popular multimedia website,
a gateway which will artificially increased traffic to a website slip stream,
which will infiltrate page views in a website.
So what they could do is they could put up a website,
make that website looks super popular,
make it look like it's gone viral.
There's something that,
that,
that Alex has not explained there.
If that's where that's from.
No,
it's not.
It's coming from Snowden.
I did,
I did a um,
red idea of the night,
uh,
with even having Mike Baker on your podcast.
He use to be in the CIA.
No,
and now he's not.
Mike hates snowed cause he was a CIA guy.
But he's a really interesting that he said something about just in passing,
Mike was talking about these websites in boosting the hits up and he goes dead.
People don't understand that.
We really are still engaged in,
in it.
He goes,
I know it's not popular to say that there's a bad guy,
but there is.
And he goes,
then you build these fucking sites and you,
you know,
because you billed them cause you want to develop relationships.
And that hadn't occurred to me.
There's certain sites are made to look more popular that the government is
running.
And then the people that come to them who are actually involved in that type of
shit,
you now see who's coming to these sites and then where they're going and you
develop relationships with these people and you get to know them that way.
And it's not always just about propaganda and sell.
A lot of it is stuff that we'll never find out about,
but he,
he,
he would explain it much better.
Just in that little moment it made me see something that I hadn't considered.
Like I'm sure they're doing dirty shit with it too.
Like those photos and,
and again,
I know the government's propaganda driven,
but there's also legit uses for it that I think might've been conquered.
There's definitely legit uses for it.
But what Snowden's point was,
whether you're having these 18 to 22 year old kids and you're giving them this
massive amount of responsibility,
right.
And that it's just not cool and there's very little oversight.
He's like,
it's very little oversight in these offices.
Yeah.
I mean,
what was Baker's,
uh,
what was his argument against Snowden?
What Snowden did?
I've only seen this,
he's on red I a lot and a,
he hates him because I tell,
I only sell a little piece of it on the episode we did together.
But Mike's a really logical,
you'd love him.
Like he's a great talker.
He's funny.
He's like,
he's not some,
you know,
uh,
propaganda spewing asshole.
He's got his talking points,
but he's a really smart dude.
I think you'd,
you'd love to have it.
I would love to have him.
I would love to hear what the argument against Snowden is because in my opinion,
what he was doing was something,
what,
what he released was information that let the American people know that the
government was doing something that's unconstitutional and they were doing it
and they were doing it like they had the right to do it and they're going to
continue to have the right to do it.
They're gonna kill you.
And if they catch him,
they gonna lock him in jail for exposing in a way,
everything that Obama said when he was running for office,
he said that they were going to have greater protection of whistle blowers.
Right.
Anybody that was showing that they were doing something right,
that if someone was doing something that was illegal,
he was going to protect them.
Meanwhile,
they had a release,
they had a delete that off of his website because they kept it up until like a
year and a half ago.
And then finally,
you know,
people started pointing it out when all the Snowden shit was going down the hope
and change website and they finally redacted at all.
But
yeah,
it's a,
it's a very weird cause I get,
I agree with you.
I think that uh,
what he did in the,
to a certain degree is really good.
Like I don't want the government having that ability.
My point of view on it as I'm so disgusted with the public and I'm so disgusted
with what voyeurs we are and how we refuse to acknowledge that and how we sit
there and judge people like Donald Sterling,
I like the guy's a twat obviously,
but the way everyone sits there and fucking self righteously judges this guy and
I love,
I love the fact that he's a fucking miserable parrot voiced 81 year old who now
wants to fucking hire private investigators to go after every NBA owner and
uncover shit.
It's like they,
none of them stood tall and said,
look,
this guy is a piece of garbage.
But you know what?
I've said a lot of ugly things in my private life style and what he said was
mine or compared to the privacy of his own home,
there was no racial slurs.
What he said is,
don't bring these black guys around them.
Take pictures with them.
Molly's trying to fuck this chick,
by the way.
Yeah.
He's just trying to get past all this and fucker.
He's like,
I mean that's his,
when he said,
when he was talking about,
he goes,
look,
I was trying to get laid.
I was telling me,
look,
don't bring these guys around.
He even said to her,
if you want to fuck him,
fuck him.
He's,
he's my favorite person.
No.
Is he a racist?
Probably Z.
A piece of shit by all accounts.
Sure,
but so what?
How do you find a guy two point $5 million for telling his girlfriend not to
bring black guys around the games.
That's crazy.
Right?
It's his girlfriend.
He's not saying you don't associate with those people because they are below
human.
He's not saying anything crazy and racist.
He's like,
look,
you bring in guys around that are definitely going to fuck you and it makes me
look bad.
Yeah.
That's the only slowly it's always saying,
and even if he was being a creepy racist,
even if he was the fact that it was in private and bay,
they got the,
I think in California there's only two states,
one party,
a notification states.
I'm thinking they're into New York is one.
Yeah.
[inaudible] and I think that uh,
the fact that was illegally obtained information.
Yeah.
And again,
I think the guy I told Jabar wrote a fucking genius article on why this guy
should have been God after,
before for a lot of the housing discrimination and stuff,
but not for this.
Right.
And no one gave a fuck when it was that,
but now that it's language,
they're going after him.
Yeah.
And then they're using the housing discrimination stuff to justify their going
after I'm about this.
I'm like,
no,
look,
the housing discrimination stuff is fucked.
Your right.
If you want to find them for that,
then it should be some sort of another,
not the
NBA.
NBA just reacted again.
They panicked,
they reacted quickly and not one of these owners has a clean fucking backyard.
None of,
maybe they haven't said racist stuff,
but a lot of them are probably fucked around on their wives.
A lot of them have probably said sexist stuff.
So I love the fact of sterling's going to hire a,
uh,
but,
but this is like how dirty it gets when people aren't honest about our own
ugliness.
Like,
and that's why when a guy likes Snowden does what he does,
it's like,
ah,
I,
the NSA,
the NSA.
Yeah,
there's Shitty,
but fuck the public.
Because the public didn't stand up in,
in,
in the fucking defensive privacy when it was Donald Sterling.
We only care about it when it's ourselves.
And if we were a public that would never have tolerated that from the
government,
they wouldn't do it.
Like,
you know,
or they would,
they would do it and be terrified to do it knowing that we were going to revolt,
but they know that we'll just take it because we're nosy cons and we don't
really bother.
We liked,
we like invading people's privacy and tiger woods,
his text messages,
oh,
we can't get enough.
A Mel Gibson's voicemails but fucking scumbags just sitting home wringing our
hands.
Have you ever heard
with sociologists say about that when it comes to gossip and things along those
lines?
They believe that we,
we no longer have communities like we used to have when we were tribal
organizations.
When were groups of 50 to 150 200 people,
small groups.
And then we used to know each other's business cause we had to be aware.
We had to know who was a good guy,
who was a bad guy.
We had to talk and exchange and we also had to figure out what other people
liked and tolerated what was accepted on our community.
And now we don't really have the sort of relationships with our neighbors
anymore.
And so celebrity gossip,
gossip,
it's in the news.
Whenever someone is doing something,
it becomes extra juicy to us because we don't,
we don't have this normal communication amongst the people that,
you know,
we,
we have in our local community that,
yeah,
that is true.
I mean we do.
Who Do you know in your building?
I'm almost numb.
It's funny as we speak,
Obama's in my building in New York doing a fundraiser.
He doesn't leave the building.
He's in my,
in my apartment building.
And you get in there while he's there or is it for some fucking pain that Dick,
I probably could,
I mean he might be gone already.
He was some Democratic fundraiser,
but I don't know.
I don't know.
The point is,
The neighbor he's seeing,
he's probably seeing something,
one of the neighbors for a fundraiser and I have no idea who it is.
How annoying.
I would love to be there though.
It's be kind of fun just to be in the elevator with him.
I don't think male meet you a Kakou together.
I'll meet you a calculus fucking who I saw the other day,
by the way,
walking into the building and I'm like,
hi Ha.
He literally,
if a fucking rabbit ran by,
he would have recognized it more than me,
who?
He sat as close as we are and talked.
He's a genius,
but he's a fucking weird dude.
He's a very weird,
oh,
hi.
Hey.
He'll,
he's frightened to always make fun of because he refuses to,
like,
you just can't say hello.
Hi Dr Kako.
Ha.
He's just so,
it's like how many times you've been assaulted that you're so timid when people
say hello to you,
he gets shit on by other scientists,
you know?
Well,
he oversimplifies it.
Like I like,
uh,
I like Brian Greene is the guy's name and I also like a,
and Neil degrasse Tyson yells because they simplify it because we are dumbbells
in comparison to them,
but they don't talk to us like we're complete.
Blithering like,
you know,
doctor Kako breaks it down,
like,
you know,
and if you look at it like everyone is in lemon drop,
it's like,
all right,
I don't have a fucking Phd,
but I understand that,
you know,
cells exist.
You can,
we can find somewhere in the middle too,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know why it doesn't.
Dr Steve Get upset at him.
Oh yeah.
Doctor Steve is my favorite.
I love him.
He's the fucking best.
Um,
cause he,
you know,
he took physics so he's another brilliant guy and he,
hey ya,
I just don't like him.
You know,
he's just,
yeah,
he's just a fucking idiot.
He just,
he knows he's smart but he doesn't like the way Dr Steve Will.
I'm doctor [inaudible] doctor [inaudible] who will kind of,
I guess,
I guess they look at him like we would look at it as a comedian doing girl fart
jokes on TV.
Like yo no,
look at,
he's got the puppet,
the puppet saying naughty things.
So boys break.
Is there anything worse than when people will come up to you and go like,
Oh,
and I love this comedian and you're like,
I want to just bite your fucking nose or you were so funny.
But you know,
my favorite is,
Oh,
you go,
oh you just ruined everything where my favorite jokey or is,
and they're like named the joke that you're like,
oh Christ,
that was the fucking joke I should be probably throat slit for that was from
1996.
Yeah.
Can't believe that he would remembers it.
I'm sad.
Yeah.
I see what jumping like getting a woody and I called it a woody.
You ever remember your old stuff and just die a little death inside?
It's online.
You can watch it.
There's a video of me from Caroline's,
not Caroline,
so rascals.
Oh Wow.
Was it the TV show?
Yeah,
we're in terrible clothes.
Tony.
Terrible jokes.
Wallpaper shirt.
Yeah.
I've got a recording somewhere of like my third or fourth time ever on stage.
I have like a whole stack of shit that I saved and one of them is like the third
or fourth time I was ever on stage.
It's a cassette recording.
It's just hot.
It could stuff.
Hot Death.
It's great to have it though.
I guess I've looked at it and fear for fucking 20 years.
Oddly humiliating exposing when you see that stuff like I wonder if other
performers look at their old shit like we did a thing on ona where we,
you maybe heard summit where we brought in our old tapes and got killed for it.
This is back in new and I brought in a tape of me from 1993 where I had like 20
minutes of material and I was a fucking please love me.
Happy go lucky.
High Energy fraud.
Like it's the type of,
it's,
it's humiliating in a weird level.
I had like purple pants and like I always talk I,
yeah,
exactly.
They were fucking nod.
They would like to have those a workout pants from the 80s.
Like those,
uh,
whenever they went with the velcro front and I would bring an enema in a bag on
stage and talking about,
cause enemas were addicting and I,
it was,
it's,
you wouldn't need to be friendly.
Collin Quinn told me like,
he's like,
it's hard for me to look at you like listening to this.
I can't acknowledge.
And this was in,
we did this in ninth,
in 2000.
So it was 17 years
after I had done it.
Wow.
But the guys that came into to talk about my tape,
Collin,
Patrice and Voss,
we're the guys that dissected my tape and it was one of the most savage assaults
of all time and we did bosses tape too when he had the fucking bad teeth and the
greasy long locks Voss looked like a rat receive boss.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
Yes.
Then he was brilliant.
I was a fast talker.
Fucking please love me.
Oh,
hunched over.
Like I used to smoke a lot of pot,
like Oh,
I met Voss.
I think in 90 or 91 we were all terrible than though.
I mean that's the one thing that I always stress to every comedian.
No one starts out good.
They just don't,
you know,
they just don't,
everyone sucks at first and especially when you're young because you don't have
shit to say.
When I was 21 with the,
who the fuck am I to be talking?
You know,
I don't have anything to say.
The only thing that I had to say about anything that was funny at all was sex
because he's the only thing I knew.
I mean everything I knew besides that me,
what did I know about politics?
What did I know about the way the world works?
What did I know about anything?
I don't know.
Opinions about anything.
Yeah,
but it wasn't even the bad jokes I had.
It wasn't even the poorly written jokes,
which they were.
It was the fucking behavior.
They'll wacky character,
like the lack of connection to who I am as a person.
That just,
it makes you want to fucking it.
I want to smash my face when I watched that,
like how did you allow yourself to do this?
Like not in just not this Voss.
Oh my God.
Look at his gold chains.
He looks like fucking Joanie from happy days when she was in her early thirties
if that fucking creepy perm,
I would an awful person and funny connection that we all have to each other.
We've all gone through the early days of comedy.
You know,
there's,
there's something that it's always going to be a weird bond that we all have
with each other and we all knew each other back in those days.
I remember the first time I met you,
I remember where we work.
I remember you is my first memory of Rogan was we were working in the upper
deck.
I think I've totally
terrible.
They were terrible gap in them.
That's the boss I met Kim by late today,
that Voss,
the guy you're looking at,
that ugly awful Voss was a pussy machinery machine.
And he would get girls like just to suck his dick in front of me or he would try
to get them to suck my Dick Voss was the fucking team player of all time.
Like he's gotten more assists than almost anybody in the business.
And he would get girls to just come in the closet and look at my Dick,
who's a great friend.
He's a good,
he's a great guy and shit on a lot buddies.
He's the best is the fucking one of the best guys I've ever known.
So where did we meet?
Uh,
upper deck.
It was a Pat Guarini Gig,
I think.
Upper deck.
Where's that lake?
A pack on New Jersey.
And you were on stage doing a bit about Tyson and Robin givens.
And you said
something about,
imagine you walk out and it's my time.
I like to talk to you for a second please.
And I just remember that line from your act.
I don't remember.
You had a lot of energy and you were,
you were very powerful performer,
but I remember that line for some reason from your act.
Wow.
I don't even remember that long.
It's probably 90 to 93.
Wow.
Back in the day.
It's a fascinating thing to go through,
isn't it?
You know it again.
Damn Dude,
I been holding it.
I'm the,
this way.
I have to fly.
I'll,
I have a bladder.
Yeah,
I do.
And I thought I,
you know,
by like Patrice,
Patrice told me fucking,
uh,
he says to me,
he goes,
you know,
you,
you have to just be checked for diabetes.
So I flew to La for the first time with Patrice and the TWA was a seven 47.
There's those two seats.
And I took the window and let that fucking behemoth have the ILC.
And I had to keep crawling over him.
And Patrice who was diabetic,
said,
uh,
you know,
you've got to get checked for diabetes now.
You pissed so much and he fucking freaked me out and I don't have it.
I just hit the pis.
But my,
during a lot of water,
lots of water,
a lot of caffeine.
I drink a diet coke before in the caffeine does something to my fucking bladder.
Yeah,
it does.
My Goldberg drinks a lot of those red bulls and when we worked together,
that guy gets up and pisses like six,
seven times during a broadcast.
I wonder how you guys do that,
by the way.
How do you not just jump up and pitch them right to this?
I guess I never noticed that he did.
I can just hold it.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know what it is.
I dig muscle boo.
I got a great deck muscle son.
Yeah,
I worked at shit out.
I don't know what it is.
I can just like,
I do three hour podcasts.
It's very rare that I have to pee during a three hour podcasts unless I drank a
lot of stuff before the show,
you know?
But if you drink any of those red bulls or those monster energy drinks,
those we'll do me if I drink one of those.
Go ahead.
Go on.
This coffee,
by the way is delicious.
It's awesome.
Right?
Right to the bathroom.
That's brave man coffee.
It's fucking great.
Caveman Coffee Company.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know what it is man.
But those monster energy drinks,
whatever it is in those taurine or whatever the fuck,
the caffeinated aspect of them.
I've always had good,
good.
Make it good bladder.
I guess.
Like I've never,
I don't have to pee that much.
Like I could drink this whole thing,
this Trenta iced coffee and I'm now a drink,
a coco cafe after.
Right.
And I still haven't peed all day.
You know,
it was cocoa cafes are God damn delicious.
They're great,
aren't they?
No one's ever had those before.
What they are is,
it's a,
and they don't pay us.
I just wanna let you know.
They just,
they're just yummy.
It tastes like a Yahoo.
Yeah.
It's coconut water and a espresso mixed together and they have different flavors
now.
Oh,
when good googly Mooglie.
It's delicious.
It.
Can I pump up,
uh,
next week?
Uh,
comic con,
uh,
we're,
we,
we're uh,
we're bringing a comic con down their comic,
uh,
at the American comedy company.
Yeah.
What Day is that?
It's a July 23rd and July 24th.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
kill Tony.
We are Thunderpussy and we also have a comedy show on the 24th with Bert
Kreischer.
It's fine.
Excellent.
And,
uh,
I am,
on the 25th,
I'm going to be at the San Jose Center for the performing arts with Tony
Hinchcliffe.
Uh,
this weekend,
uh,
Ahmed wise guys in Salt Lake City,
but it's all sold out bitches.
Sorry.
Socket heard.
That place
is cool.
Yeah,
I heard it's cool to Joey keeps saying it's awesome.
Um,
everybody that I know that's been there and you,
you worked at Salt Lake City,
right?
You might have,
yes.
Very good room.
The ally's guys.
Yeah.
I feel sorry for those people living in Salt Lake City surrounded by all those
Mormons.
But it's beautiful there.
And Mormons are nice if you're gonna be around religious nutters,
those are the people.
They're not mean people at all and all Donna's and Mormon.
She was,
yes she was.
Was she made me,
she was getting it.
No,
she probably,
I think they probably found it on that career decision.
Yeah.
I don't know why though.
She retired.
She did you say it like it was sadness?
It was like a fucking like babe Ruth retired.
I just haven't seen her in a while.
She did it.
She made that.
She made it really?
I was luckiest girl in the face of the earth.
You'll Jericho Cooper fucking suck a little little Gehrig for you.
I just wonder if she can hold in still.
That's my only question I want to know.
Cause you know she was getting baseball bats up her pussy.
She no upper ass baseball bat in her ass then she really,
yes.
Yeah.
Was a bit,
it's cool.
There's a video of it and it's just so weird to watch.
It's like,
okay,
there you go.
That's babies don't,
they don't piss all over the place.
Like I guess you can still.
Yeah,
but that's an asshole.
Her baseball bat winning her asshole.
Right.
Why does he say it holds in terms of like,
I guess those muscles re you know,
I guess,
but people do have problems.
People that like engage in those activities really do have problems stretching
out their,
their anus muscles.
I can take a little bit of a finger and I can't tell you anything else.
I was uh,
dating this chick and uh,
her roommate had sex with her boyfriend and he fucked her in the ass and uh,
her sphincter must've relaxed and she shit on him while they were sleeping and
uh,
she shit the bed.
Oh Wow.
Shit on his Dick a little bit.
I don't know it in any way.
He got up and you know,
it was like,
ah,
and the door slammed and the guy was like standing in the hallway like this,
I'm never forgets for fuck this boy.
And you know the girl was dating telling me what happened.
I'm like,
oh no shit in my mouth this year.
I told you that and that's horrible.
I know what happened.
I was any girls out who was on ecstasy for the first time and then she's
shutting my mouth.
Cause you can feel it like you see that happening.
You don't want an accidental one cause that's not going to be a good one now.
It wasn't solid either.
I think it would be preferred,
a solid one.
And there's something about a solid one.
You're like,
hey,
this kind of looks like a fucking,
you know,
uh,
a smokestack.
There's nothing cool about it,
but he's not a subject I'm really into.
But there is a woman,
this German woman who does shit porn where people shit on her and she's like the
queen of Shit Porn.
Don't ask me how.
I know that somebody posted it on my message board and I've followed a fucking
all over link hole.
I went from link to link the link till I got to her site and watch some of her
videos.
Good egg.com
winner,
winner shit dinner.
And
it's just people shitting in her mouth and she's covered in shit and it's she,
she eats it.
Yeah.
I mean it's making me swallow like,
no,
throwing up.
Oh,
it's making me a extra salivate thinking about how disgusting it was.
But she was just eating logs that were coming on his guys and guys,
ass guy,
shit's gotta be awful.
She says it's better.
She says it's spicier cause many more meat.
And she was like explaining,
yeah,
I don't want to see what's a spicy log.
She's sitting there smoking cigarettes explaining in German why she loves eating
shit.
And then she,
she's got a like a stomach of a Billy goat.
She never gets sick and she feels herself up with shit and that's great.
But you know,
but this is like the things,
there's so many types of people out there in this world.
This,
there's no normal,
there's like expectations of normality.
There's like a spectrum.
And they fought.
Most people fall into like this area,
but there's enough people out there that like watching her eat shit that she
makes a living eating shit.
She has a website [inaudible] shit.
She's a member section.
She's famous for it.
They're interviewing her,
asking her questions.
They using a camera.
I mean,
it's like the whole deal.
It's like she's,
you know,
there's,
there's uh,
not,
it's not one person that likes watching her eat shit as a whole group.
Well the funny thing is too that like when you think like the fact that she
smokes on top of it,
like if there's anything that can make your breath worse than fucking eating
some fucking to some Nazis logs and having a cigarette afterwards.
Imagine how burps Shit,
cigarettes,
shit burps.
You craft services all fucking coffee and tuna salad.
Just really awful stuff.
God,
I'm over here.
I am almost throwing up thinking about this until I see her sneezes.
Like I'm Brown.
Gray.
It's a little awful a spray.
If you had like fiber,
if you had like a cheesecloth in front of her,
you could see she can make a roar shark.
Shit,
shit,
this probably not good.
Come on.
Remember when we were kids it was really hard to find anything even remotely
fucked up.
Like did you,
when you were a kid,
did you see we're about,
I'm 46,
45 I'll be 46 in two days.
I'll be 47 in August.
Did you,
um,
did you see barnyard Betty and any of those things?
Uh,
but yeah,
the animal fucking stuff.
Yeah,
sure.
It was a video and a buddy had it and we went over to his house and watched it
and like one of us had to watch the door cause it was in the basement.
We were hovering over the v one person at the watch the door to let us know if
anybody was coming.
And then we were standing in front of this VCR,
this TV with a VCR attach to watch this really grainy video of this chick.
Like,
you know,
very mild.
Sure.
Beastiality very mild,
like blowing a donkey.
Not aggressively.
Not really that into it.
You know,
she was having sex with a pig in some weird way and a German shepherd and it was
kind of fucked,
but it was so mild in comparison
to what kids see today.
Do you ever wonder what kind of an impact that's having on them?
It's got to be freaking you out.
If you,
if you're,
if you're a,
like when I saw some hardcore porn pictures,
the dirty movie,
but if you're just seeing a beheading video or,
or legitimate car crash stuff,
or were hardcore fucking is just the normalist thing you're going to see online.
Like,
yeah,
it's got a jade.
I think that's why maybe school shooting that's,
I'm not blaming video game,
but when people be do become a certain desensitized to things,
um,
I probably sound like I'm criticizing every message if ever given.
But I do think that that has something to do with desensitizing you
to have something to do with it.
You can't say that that's the cause or someone doing something,
a born some doing something horrible and violent,
but you see so much violence and it becomes an option.
You know,
if he didn't know what a gun was,
he didn't know what,
you know,
a school shooting was.
If it didn't exist,
it wasn't on the table.
It wouldn't be something that people considered,
you know.
But because the fact we have guns,
we know about guns because of the fact that we know about school shootings,
people think,
you know what,
my fucking life is terrible.
I'm all fucked up on antidepressants.
I'm going to go shoot up my school.
You know,
it is all those things do factor into the possibility of someone doing
something.
But you can't blame those things.
It's like I've said that I think that we have a gun problem,
a mental health problem,
rather disguise as a gun problem.
That's what I think it is more than anything because you can give a lot of
people guns and they would never do anything wrong.
Right.
But then he gave her that,
you know,
one fucking one one like what was the kid that Alonza,
Alonza,
Adam Lanza Lanza would affect his name was his mother had they got around the,
you know,
so even if you're not the crazy person,
even if your kid is the fucking wide eyed,
you know me,
me,
me shitbag that he was the fucking PW.
I hate the pupil in the middle of the eye with white all around it.
And I know some people get mad at me,
but it's a real condition.
Got Up.
So sick of people getting upset there.
Shouldn't Jen move?
He had a weird pupil.
Oh you,
no,
but I'm saying a lot of the look in their eyes,
Adderall ice.
I know somebody is on Adderall is when you look at,
you can see the white around their Ibo.
You know,
that's cause they're just like this.
Yeah.
Like oh I see what you're saying.
Some Wacko,
you can see that fucking act like Garfield.
You know,
I'm sure plenty of people don't have that aren't mentally ill who have that.
But the,
the nuts I've seen all have that.
Well Wa being wide eyed,
being
accelerated,
being on amphetamines or you know,
when you,
when you're putting kids on Ritalin and you're putting kids on Adderall and all
these different,
those are stimulants.
You know,
one of the things that they use to treat ADHD and add,
those are stimulants.
You know,
you're,
you're jacking kids up on all kinds of crazy shit.
And that's just,
that's just those things.
What about the things that they put him on that or antidepressants and all these
things that don't have a long history of where you're radically altering human
neurochemistry,
radically altering it on a daily basis with really hardcore chemicals.
That's the one thing that nobody likes to talk about when it comes to these
schools shootings,
you know the,
you know,
not meet correlation of causation or whatever the fuck that term is that that
you can't necessarily connect them.
You,
you can necessarily connect them you that you can't say it's the a hundred
percent of the cause,
but when 90% of all the people that are school shooters are on antidepressants
or are coming off of antidepressants suffering when withdrawal of
antidepressants,
it wasn't point in time that they start looking at these chemicals that
radically altered the way people react to stress,
the way people react to life itself,
the way people react to negative influences.
Like,
I had a friend that was on Zoloft and she said that when she was on it,
she didn't care about anything.
Like she was going to write a book called,
I lost a year of my life about being on Zoloft cause for a year nothing bothered
her,
nothing bothered her.
And you would think that someone who's a fucking psycho,
right.
You put them on that shit.
It's also not going to bother them to kill people.
I mean,
just totally makes sense.
Right.
They went to [inaudible] as a kid,
but my parents I think said no thank God,
they like me being creative.
Yeah.
And the funny Mandy having a lot of extra energy and anxiety that people can
misinterpret that as like,
oh,
we got to medicate this kid to make them quote unquote normal.
Yeah.
Always a Weirdo.
I mean,
you know,
I was a little fucking Weirdo and,
but that's how you make a comedian.
That is true.
Yes.
Nobody,
nobody brings that up,
you know?
No,
no one ever brings that up in school.
Like,
you know,
Jimmy,
the way you look like I,
I,
there's a,
a gal who works at this office that I go to.
That's very funny.
She's always saying really funny shit.
So I asked her to,
I go,
how come you're not a comedian?
Have you ever thought about being a comedian?
And she goes,
no.
I go,
you're,
you're a comedian.
You just never done it.
Like you've,
you've got all the traits,
right.
You know,
you're always,
you're quick with Whit,
you're always trying to make people laugh.
You're always like,
she says creative shit.
She's very funny.
Like,
why don't you,
why don't you become a QB?
You ever thought about it?
She's like,
no.
I was like,
think about it.
How old is she?
28 not too late.
You were 38 I'll tell you to give it up.
Yeah.
28 you can still to kill Tony.
I'll put her up.
I don't think she's ready.
You know,
I mean you plant seeds like that and someone said and who knows what they're
going to take.
But there's a lot of people out there that that is what they could do and they
probably have a skill.
They probably have a talent rather,
and they just never been a encouraged don't when he encourages you to do that.
Yeah.
Cause any guidance counselor ever said to a kid he should be a standup comic.
You like doing drugs.
Look,
you'd never show up on time.
You don't do your homework.
You're funny.
Go be a comic.
Yeah.
They never encourage you to get in the city.
Right.
You know,
if your music,
they encourage you to take me as a class.
Well they probably gets here to that part of the arts and drama alone.
Take a class and see if your standup comedy is one of the least respected art
forms that's most loved.
Yeah.
As far as like the process of becoming a standup comedian,
the option of becoming a standup convenient is so often like my own parents.
My parents didn't have a hard time with me kickboxing,
but they didn't want me to do comedy doing comedy.
Like you're not funny.
This is going to be terrible.
Yeah.
There's something intangible about a comment that just scares people.
Well,
they feel like you're going to be
a loser,
you're going to be a loser,
you're acting.
Cause no one wants to be the one who bombs.
And just to see someone you love up there making an ass out of themselves and
not be in funny like,
oh,
how awful it did for a girl to go out with a guy she's dating who consistently
sucks on stage.
That's gotta be,
that's just kind of make her not want to fuck him.
I'll for sure awful.
Well,
I've brought dates to shows and I bombed.
Yes.
Feel it.
They just didn't want to have nothing to do with me.
Can feel it.
You know,
back in the day when,
when I first started,
I could have bombed,
I wouldn't have a good set,
you know,
maybe three to three sets in a row and then every fourth or fifth set easily can
go into the toilet easily.
So you take a girl with you to a show boy that was taking a risk.
I never do it.
I mean now I'll do it,
come see you to sell it,
but I'm working on stuff or whatever on the nights that I'm there.
I hate bringing people to shows,
especially when you're working on stuff because when you working on stuff,
you're not trying to do the best show as much as you're trying to get material
and like format and get it to get and you'll sacrifice a few minutes.
Oh yeah.
I mean I,
I worked on a new bit last night and I just,
I knew,
I'm like,
while I'm doing this,
this is virgin territory is completely new bit.
I don't know where it's going.
And if someone was there to see you,
who knows how you're going to pull out of that,
you might not pull out.
Well,
yeah.
So I,
I warned them though and I'm like,
it's going to by that clear my throat because the butter,
it's fuck,
I love it,
but it makes me fucking sound like fucking Ian Watkins on the stand.
Yeah.
It's probably not the best thing to serve people a show.
They talk for three hours.
No,
he'd have some cottage cheese.
Goggle it,
this and then talk for three hours.
Fuck it.
I'll,
can I be fun?
I'm going to forget.
Can I plug my show?
But I keep it,
I'm really bad at that.
Please plugs.
I can't do it naturally,
so I have to just stop the flow of everything.
Plug whore.
People want to hear it.
I'm doing a talk show and vice,
ah,
which is why I'm out in Los Angeles right now.
And it comes out next Wednesday,
the 23rd.
Um,
you know,
it's a talk show that I host and what is it?
It's just me doing a monologue and a little sketch and then interviewing guests.
And my first guests were actually Dana and Mike Tyson together.
Wow.
What a fucking favor.
Dana did me mad.
And that's a Tyson.
Yeah,
they were great.
They were really great.
And just do it in front of an audience.
Live audience where I'm in New York.
Wow.
We did four pilot episodes and uh,
it was,
it was a very odd thing because I wanted the crowd on top of me like they're lay
audiences like from where you are to me on top.
Like I wanted it like comedian style.
So uh,
the camera angles where they had to,
we,
it was hard for us to edit anything because it was supposed to be a 30 minute
show,
but I want to talk to these guys who wouldn't like an hour and 20 so we had to
chop down to an hour.
They let me make it an hour pilot episode for vice.com or is it vice.com so it's
all going to be online.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
It comes out to the 23rd and then there's going to be one a week for four weeks
and hopefully people like the different shows and you know,
the monologues I'm allowed to kind of say what I want to say.
They didn't creatively fuck with me at all.
Like that's awesome man.
They were great.
I mean everywhere you go,
they're telling you don't say this and you know he's afraid of frustrating for a
comedian.
Well,
Shane Smith is one of my favorite people ever.
I just love him.
He's the absolute fucking Adam.
Yeah,
he sent me a fucking were going back and forth.
He was texting me,
trying to get me to go to Africa with him.
I was like,
bitch,
are you out of your fucking mind?
He wants me to go to some new island that some island rather that they have
where they've taken all these monkeys and apes.
They experimented with and shot up with diseases and aids and all this stuff and
they've dropped them off when they're done with their experiment and they,
they bring them to some island.
So there's an island,
like a planet of the apes island that's filled with all these monkeys and apes
that have gone through all these medical experiments.
He wanted me to go there with him.
I'm like,
that is the last place I'm going,
man.
If you want me to go to The Bahamas and drink my ties with Anthony Bordain I'm
in.
I'm not,
I'm not going to an AIDS infected monkey island.
Yeah.
How about Shane invites you somewhere fun?
Like you want to like get blown.
All right.
He doesn't want to go anywhere and everywhere you go places,
let's go to the Ukraine.
Fuck you.
Let's go to North Korea.
Eh,
not happening,
dude.
He's the one that interviewed uh,
a fucking general butt naked.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
They're like,
send another guy.
No,
he's gangster as fuck.
He gets dirty.
Yeah,
he really does.
And it's like,
I don't think there's anybody on top of a company of that size that is going to
those places.
I'm hoping he stops doing that.
He's not going to stop doing it.
He's in the group.
He was somewhere crazy the other day.
He was like in the Ukraine or something.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Yeah.
It goes to all those places and it's a part of his life and he comes back with a
fucking burden,
bro.
He's come straight from the airport right here and started drinking and we've
done podcast together and it's,
you could feel the burden on him,
you know,
like,
yeah.
What does that I,
this is Jim's,
uh,
oh,
play this,
play this.
I liked the problem.
I don't like,
I like,
I'm,
hi,
I'm Jim Norton.
Be sure to watch my brand new show on vice
next.
Great.
How could you got like that?
You like it.
Okay.
Thank you.
I,
those are legit laugh.
uh,
I,
I called the Best Expression Collin everyday was shame spiral.
I can't watch myself.
I ever,
Like I get fucking humiliating,
but that's one of the reasons why you're really good.
You know,
it's hard.
I don't like watching myself either.
It's,
you know,
it's whenever I sit down on a radio show like they used to do it on k rock,
every time I would do it I would sit down,
they would play this whole thing of a bunch of clips in my stand up and then add
a context.
Just punchlines like stop making me uncomfortable.
Stop it,
don't do it,
don't play it.
He just made me feel a lot better than thank you.
Cause that was spent all day.
I was panicking about that promo going on.
I'm like,
nobody's going to laugh at it.
I take it a promo.
I have been mixed.
I did another promo with fucking with,
with with Tyson and of course Dana is in it and I'm like that one I felt more
secure with because this was just me.
I'm like no one will like it.
Like great.
Thank you Joe.
That made me feel a lot sacral naked in the background.
It's hard to say cause the TVS,
no,
she a Bra.
Our connection is we have to fix that and make it sticky to the TV color
broadly.
It's Kinda hard to say.
It looks like she's naked.
It was fun.
Whatever.
It is fucking hilarious.
I made me feel a lot better if I was really genuinely panicked.
Look,
I'm a child,
I'm a fan of people throwing up.
I hosted fear factor for six years.
Throwing up to me was always funny.
It is right?
It is kind of for me.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean just the ridiculousness of it all.
You sitting on the edge of the bed,
her throwing up in a bucket I'm in and I'll say this,
they eddy Moretti and knows and he's like,
no,
I think that's the best one we should lead with.
And I was against it.
I was like,
no,
I don't think so.
And it's like sometimes people just,
I have to remember that there are people that see things from the outside that
are,
that are no shit that I don't know and have a better eye than I do.
And it's like,
you know how you're married to your stuff,
man,
when you're performing or whatever.
And it's like there's people that can just see things and detach from the
emotion of it and go to clearly like now though,
this is the way to start.
Like I was wrong about that and he was right and it's like,
it's really hard for me to think in those terms that I don't know what the fuck
I'm always talking about.
It's hard to,
when you're going over your material,
when you're editing like a special,
you lose the idea of what's funny and what's not funny.
You see the bits too many times and could get,
they get really blurry sometimes it gets real confusing and you get a fan.
I'm a very bad collaborator.
Like we had to edit the,
the,
the interview with,
with Dana and Mike and I loved all of it cause it was honest and funny and free
flowing and you know,
Tyson was hilarious and Dana was fucking great and it was like we had to chop,
it just cannot 40 minute cause I went 40 minutes.
So it's the internet,
but they way that they're letting me do it was they've already doubled how long
they'll let me do it.
I'm okay with that and a lot and some that was just literally we were throwing
too.
We had to do a couple of throws cause the way vice releases a video is they'll
have more than one part to it.
They just masters at that shit.
So I forgot to do that.
I during the interview I didn't do that.
So we had to guard,
we just got to get a couple of pickups which we needed.
So we had to get like,
all right,
we'll be right back,
watch this.
So we had to tape them at the end and they were doing that and we're talking
about something.
But the one we're talking about,
um,
I had to take this pickup and put it in the middle.
Just a couple of minor things.
But I got so fucking territorial about stuff.
You don't want to cut any of it.
But they were actually great when they didn't bust my balls about any of the
content at all.
I don't understand wanting to edit things that are on the Internet if it,
unless it's some insane length.
This was just the,
the cuts we made,
there was very little in the content area.
It was only because I didn't know how they did videos.
Like I didn't realize that we have to do it in more than one part.
And they probably had told me that,
and I just forgot in that moment because it was my first episode.
So I should have said like what I should have done was to keep in pace with the
way they do is because every series they do is really,
I've watched a million up,
they're all released in a few parts.
So if I'm going along,
I should have said,
all right,
it's about x amount of time,
we'll be right back or go to the next,
whatever the fuck I should have said and then done it that way.
But I just didn't know to do that.
So you know what I think,
I think that's the wrong way to do it.
I think the way you did it as the right way,
dude,
organically have a conversation and then have all the throws in post.
What do you have to fucking be there when you do it?
Just say you know,
having the middle of the coffee,
like the conversations have pauses.
Say we'll be back with episode two next week and we can do that.
Why not?
Why would you want to make someone have some nonorganic throw in the middle of a
conversation.
Like that's goofy.
That's just chops up the flow of the conversation in the thought process.
That may have been my mistake.
Then you don't need to like they know how to,
the thing that they do is they release video.
They know what gets the views.
The part one's the part two.
He's like they tried to explaining it to me like how it works as a business
model and you know I'm looking at it from like,
like you just said,
I want to have the conversation and they were like things don't normally go
cause my set's very plain.
I like,
I like the Dick Cavett Mike Douglas,
like those fucking guys.
So I did it because I,
you know,
they're not going to just,
I should have just said,
hey look,
we'll be right back or maybe done it in post,
but I just didn't think to do that at the moment.
They're like,
we just got to get a couple of pickups.
That was the stage manager.
I'm like,
okay,
like maybe I could have said to him now do it in post.
And he might've been fine with it,
but again,
it was such a learning,
and I hate to 60 sound like such a Douche,
but it was,
they gave me so much ability to do what I want without fucking with me.
That I might've made a couple of like,
oh yeah,
I should've done this instead of that.
Right.
Well it seems like you could probably figure that out as you go along.
Whenever you start something out.
It always has.
Like,
you know,
there's always this bumps.
I mean,
and they gave me an extra episode.
We were supposed to do three and then they were like,
we might do two because of scheduling.
And then I sat down with editing.
He goes,
well,
fuck,
why don't we just try for,
and they just threw it up.
But like that's how they do things.
They throw an extra episode.
So I had David tells the guest and I had does Shirad small in Boston a pace for
me and it was just fucking funny hanging with three other Comedians,
you know?
And that kind of felt like a much different one than Tyson and data.
Do you think,
what do you think is going to go down with September when your contract is up?
October 4th I don't know.
I mean like I love the Gig,
I love performing.
But you love the Gig.
The same with Anthony.
Not of course not.
No,
no.
I mean,
I mean the idea of performing either alone or with other people.
Right.
I want this thing to work because I want my own thing.
Like I've done so many things.
The vice thing.
Yeah,
Jim Norton show.
I want to have my own thing too,
because you feel like a more complete performer when you're not always with Opie
and Anthony Are Collin Quinn or Louis C K or Amy Schumer's put me on her show.
Like I don't always want to be on somebody else's thing.
Um,
so I love the idea of performing on the radio.
I love doing it with,
Oop,
I love doing it with opie and Anthony Moore because,
and I like to say the same thing of Opie left.
Like I honestly do love being a part of that radio show.
Being without Anthony is difficult and it would say the same thing.
It's just like,
it's,
it's hard to realize how much space a person fills in your life until they're
not there.
Like,
I mean,
we all know Anthony's a comic gene,
that's easy to say,
but it's like the little moments,
like when there's that chair,
I mean,
I'm
close.
I said closer to,
um,
to Anthony that I do to you every day,
five days a week for 10 years.
And now he's just gone.
And it's really hard to get used to that empty seat.
Whether he's saying something funny or whether he's just doing a stupid Iraq
joke or a little aside or just pie.
It's like this whole fucking vacuum of this,
this great powerful brain that used to be,
you know,
a foot away from it or just talking about things.
He's a fascinating guy.
He's got a lot of information in his head.
He can talk about anything for any length of time,
anything he could be.
And we've said that like he porter,
and I've said this before,
but Patrice said that Anthony can access funny faster than anybody he'd ever
known.
Like he just had the ability to access being funny immediately on any subject.
Like if you're talking like you know,
he was a tin knocker,
he would put in air conditioning vents and he can walk you through that in a
fascinating way and be funny about it and be captivating with it.
Me,
I and I,
I just die telling a story.
I lose people in me.
It's a joke I've done,
but I meant this sincerity of it that if I was on nine 11 on the,
if I made it out of the first tower,
I would lose people halfway through the story.
Like I just have no ability to go from the beginning to the middle to the end
and keep people locked in.
Did you guys have a meeting with serious after this is over?
I know we talked to Scott,
I talked to Scott on the phone and he goes,
look,
we're going to try to move forward with you and opie and see how it happens.
He goes,
work through it organically on the air.
They didn't tell us how to do it.
They didn't say don't bad mouth the company don't.
He said worked through it organically on the air and what we'll see what
happens.
So I mean,
see what happens.
They completely closed the idea of Anthony ever coming back.
I don't think so.
Um,
and,
and they've given me no indication.
So I'm careful how I say that because I don't want the fans getting like I'm
putting false hope out there,
but I'm,
I'm just being truthful is they,
it doesn't feel final to me and maybe that's my own denial or my own lack of
willingness to admit that this thing could be over.
Like it was really sad man.
Last time I saw,
I don't think I went to his fucking 4th of July party and I was very depressed
driving home.
Like I know I'm going to be okay financially and I know like,
hey there's other show could take off.
Hey you got stand up.
Hey you got,
but just the idea that this thing you love to do like art,
this chapter is closed.
Like just fucking depresses me,
depresses me to listen to it.
I can imagine if it was me every day,
day in day out being a part of it,
you know,
every time I did it I loved it.
I mean I had a great time doing your show.
So my favorite radio show of all time without a doubt,
it's a real conversation.
You have real moments and the laughs somebody played for me recently are,
they sent me a link to Jim Norton's laugh compilation.
There's just times where people have made me laugh on the shell and I listened
to part one and two because a point is not me laughing.
It's the things,
and you know,
most of those labs have come from Anthony more than any gas or anybody.
And some of the things that,
if he did a thing recently or years ago
that I heard two days ago when we were talking about people who have shot
themselves in the head and survived and Anthony did the voice of the guy who
survived and he just wanted to,
it was an immediate,
he became the guy who had shot himself in the fucking head and survived there.
He's talking about how he just has a more positive outlook and I'm howling
listening to it in,
in the clip and I'm listening to it like,
yeah,
two days ago and I'm laughing all over again.
Like I forgot that bit ever existed,
but God,
this cocksucker made me fucking laugh.
And I'm not talking about him like he's dead,
but I mean that's how valuable a thing he is.
Like I can,
I can't listen to two radio bits.
They made a big mistake.
I think they made a big steak for a couple reasons.
One,
I think that they made a big mistake because I think it's,
it's going to open the door more to the Internet because people are going to
look at that as the only last remaining true free speech option.
Yep.
Because that's what it is.
Look,
you can,
you could say you don't like this podcast.
You can decide that I'm offensive.
You can do it,
but you can't stop it.
I mean you might,
even though the host might say,
we don't want to host you anymore,
I'll find another host.
You know those sponsors might say,
we don't want to be your sponsor anymore.
Well guess what?
I'll do it with no sponsor.
We did it with no sponsors for years.
This is the only real option where you're your own producer,
your own director,
your own,
you're the whole thing.
You're the performer.
You're the whole thing.
That's where it's sad because just like a standup is entirely responsible for
your act that you put on stage.
If you had some producer hovering over your fucking shoulder every time you
wrote a bit,
every time you were thinking about putting together a set list,
every time you are going up and doing a show,
right,
they would review it afterwards.
That would be gross.
That would take all the fun out of being a comic.
Yeah,
it would be awful.
I mean,
that's why I'm a bad collaborator because you're so used to having absolute and
ultimate control of things.
So you're a perfect example.
Think about you and you as a successful performer and personality.
Who the fuck would have ever thought you could have made a mainstream career out
of talking about your love of trannies,
talking about shit and Piss and shit in in each other's mouths and p and on
people,
Monster Rain.
Just look at the honest things that you've tackled and because you're honest,
because you're funny.
If you had to vet that through somebody else,
if you had to have that filter through some sort of a mainstream producer,
it would've never happened.
Never work.
You're absolutely right.
I mean that's why you're right.
The Internet is the last place where at least,
I mean for now,
who the fuck knows what happens with that?
But all that stuff you did,
you did on serious,
serious had a different approach when they first came out.
They've slowly but surely clamped down from that Condoleezza Rice incident.
That's where it was like,
Ooh,
you could get in trouble for something that someone says on a radio show that
isn't even like a guest.
Like I mean,
isn't even one,
one of the hosts,
right?
He was at your show could get canceled.
The homeless guy.
Yeah,
and they were going to fire us that Eric Logan say that was XM wasn't this year.
It was,
and this is how,
what happened?
The fucking the NAB,
the National Association of broadcasters.
Somebody on that side,
I think was what was pushing it.
Could the story went on drudge and Brietbart will this hurt the merger?
And again,
the guys who ran the this when they're about to merge,
will this injure the merger?
And man it was $1 billion at stake and it wasn't going to hurt the merger,
but they fucking panicked.
And these are all different people that are in charge now.
Uh,
but they're like well all and they don't know how to deal with stuff.
So they get the phone call.
The Guy Nate I think was running XM at the time or coupon narrow.
What do you think of this thing?
They said a homeless guy said he wants to rape Condoleezza Rice and felt why?
Like he,
he's worried about a billion dollar merger and he,
and he,
and I'm not,
I'm not defending them suspending us,
but I try to put myself in there like the,
and this is a guy I mentioned Louis,
cause he's a good,
he's a good nonemotional reactor to things and he'll look at things and go,
well they're just trying to do this.
And like Louie will give you a very logical reason as to why something's
happening.
And it's like,
yeah,
I wish I would've seen that.
I get too angry and emotional and you're like,
fuck that.
And they're saying,
and then I'll go like,
okay,
that's $1 billion company.
They're not used to this.
And they hear this guy wants to fucking first lady raped Bush or George Bush and
they're laughing about it.
Merger might be threatened to pipe the fuck 'em get rid of him.
And He'd just panics.
Isn't it fascinating though that you're talking about a billion dollar company?
Okay.
Sirius XM billion dollar company.
What exactly are they selling?
What they're selling is content.
Who delivers that content?
Guys like opie and Anthony,
guys like Jim Norton.
There's selling your ability to be entertaining.
Other than that,
it's just music.
How do you have $1 billion company that's just selling music?
Well,
I don't,
that's where my argument would be to it looked the talk thing is the last,
like the last thing you guys have,
and this is for any,
a terrestrial radio to the last thing.
You have his original talk content and their point back would be,
well that's a great thing that we have,
but we also have,
um,
whether it's a celebrity,
people doing shit or we have sports that you can't get across.
Let's say we have the MBA,
we have a major league baseball,
but I'm just saying that's what they would say.
Yeah.
But nobody's paying for that.
Let's be honest.
They're paying for stern and they're paying for opiate.
Anthony.
I hope so man.
It's cause you said Spotify and like those like Pandora,
they used to be,
I like Sirius radio cause they had like the 30s to forties to 50s,
whatever and all the different radio stations.
Now did you just put Spotify put anything you wanted as the,
you know,
yeah,
I mean I,
I get almost all my shit from iTunes.
I don't ever listen to music in my car anymore unless it's coming off of my
phone.
I just,
it's just,
I don't need to,
you don't need to anymore.
You don't need them anymore.
And what the last thing that the exciting is things like stern and things like
opion Anthony where you can have a guy who is
just freewheeling,
same whatever he wants,
doesn't have to worry about language restrictions,
does it have to worry about anything and the fact that he can get fired for
saying the same things that he's always said on his show,
the sang them in a text message that they're so ignorant that they can't
recognize that this is,
you're taking it out of context.
You're taking it from a guy who has just recently been assaulted.
You're taking it from a guy,
probably had a couple of drinks and then when he said it and he shouldn't have
done it,
he fucked up.
He definitely shouldn't have gone on that Twitter rampage.
He should have said it on a video
and you know what podcast or I'm the show,
the show on the show.
It would have been perfect,
but have been a great episode.
All of that would have been fun.
And,
and Keith Robinson pointed out,
he's like the teasing.
We could've given him a,
the teasing.
Beautiful.
But,
but I don't know if that's something that will ever change.
Like they may at one point,
we do kind of understand that maybe he's,
you know,
he's a valuable asset to the like,
again,
I don't,
I don't know why I don't get that feeling cause they haven't said to me we'll
bring him back.
They really haven't.
And I never want to give fans,
I'm not trying to keep fans from Caribou.
It literally is just a feeling,
a gut feeling.
He didn't drop any bombs.
He didn't go on this.
And I've talked to him enough to know what his intent was and maybe I'm just
naive dummy in me,
but I keep thinking,
man,
he should come back.
He can come back.
Just give it some time.
I just keep hoping for that.
You can come back.
I think if they gave it some time,
he definitely can come back in the context of what he said.
Well,
it wasn't that bad.
You know,
I wouldn't have been happy if it was my company and I had shareholders and all
that jazz,
but I obviously I would never be that guy anyway.
I would never be a fucking head of a big company.
I'm just not built for it.
But you got to recognize the entertainment quality,
you know the entertainment aspect of that guy,
the head of the entertainment possibilities of keeping the show together.
It's because without that,
all you have is stern.
You know,
you mean obviously you guys are still together and they'll still be a great
show,
but it's not the same show.
No,
it's not.
And you,
you leave open the door for Anthony's starting his own thing,
some wildly successful thing.
And the Internet,
which also look,
if someone comes along and they put together some sort of an advertising budget
and they say,
hey listen,
we would like to do the oop.
We'd like to host the opie and Anthony podcasts on the Internet.
We'll take x percentage of the,
the,
the advertisers.
We've already got it lined up.
We have a big launch.
We're gonna do it around Thanksgiving.
Someone's going to fuck a Turkey live on the air,
you know,
whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
You start,
you start doing,
you come up with some idea to do something completely free and wild on the
Internet.
A big advertising push,
buy Billboards Times Square,
you know,
fuck serious.
We're doing it on the Internet.
You know ONA is back and it's free.
Download it online.
You don't need to pay for a subscription anymore.
Anybody can get it on your phone.
Do,
I mean you could do it.
The way we do it,
we're,
we're available on were,
were available online as an MP three were available from iTunes.
We're available on Stitcher,
on Youtube,
on Ustream,
on Vimeo.
Have you just did something like that?
It would be [inaudible]
Yannick.
Yeah,
maybe.
You're right man.
We have thought it and again,
we're up in October 4th we don't know.
And I,
and I'm,
I'm,
we honestly don't know what we do from here.
Like again,
[inaudible] and I are doing the show,
bringing guests in and just performing and it's like we both feel the fucking
loss.
Go through vice,
do it all through vice.
There'll be a wonderful promotion vehicle to view you guys to do.
Opie and Anthony Live through vice.
They'll set you up with a studio,
do it all online through this show as a video online,
and do this show,
have it available as a podcast.
Free downloads they provide you with advertisers.
Wouldn't be hard to do.
Shane could hook that up in five seconds.
They can make one phone call and it would be,
the wheels would be in motion.
I would,
uh,
I would love to do that.
And that's a guy that you,
you know,
like shit can get really crazy and everyone's going to be fine.
Yeah.
Shane,
I mean,
looked at the fact the fact that they didn't break my boy,
like I,
everyone says like,
oh,
we were allowed to do it.
We want guys,
but like they,
I can't believe the amount of like,
if this thing fails,
it is absolutely my fault.
It is 100% my fault.
I can't blame the company.
They fucking got gotten my ear and fuck.
They didn't give a fuck.
They really didn't.
It's this one is on me.
If it succeeds,
I did a great job.
Kurt Metzger helped me and Jesse Joyce contributed a little,
I tell contributed some brilliant stuff,
but vice allowed me freedom.
Totally.
The monologues are like are just fucking are exactly what I wanted to do
monologue wise.
Um,
I have links that I,
which I,
they can't be posted but I was going to send you,
but they,
they took so long to get them to me.
Um,
and I'm just so bad at this shifts,
get it to me later.
It doesn't matter.
Listen,
whatever,
whenever it comes out,
we'll promote the shit out of me next Wednesday,
the 23rd,
next Wednesday,
the 23rd.
All right,
I'm going to,
I'll tweet it,
I'll tweet it when it's coming out.
I'll tweet it when it's on a tweet.
All four episodes.
I'll tweet links and websites.
Whatever you need to do,
man,
it's not going to fail.
It's going to be great being a how it is man.
I,
I the fucking like,
I know intellectually,
yeah.
I'm a funny guy and I think it's,
there's things that will be fixed in the show.
Like you know,
cause again,
it's a new thing.
But I also think like it came out funny,
like I'm happy with how it came out.
There was a lot of really funny lines.
Oh cow would fix this and fix that and you live in your learn.
It's going to be great,
but I know that that part of you that's never happy,
always going to have issues about things.
That's also what makes you good because it keeps you,
keeps you like checking and second guessing and working on things and keeps you
striving for a high standard.
That's the,
it's the,
the dark inner secret of all comedians that were never really happy with what we
do.
I obsess like that prom all,
I was like,
I was out in the parking lot with my luggage,
talking to my fucking manager on the phone.
I'm like,
I don't know why they're there.
The no one's gonna like that one.
I'm just,
I'm having a fucking panic attack.
And it's moments like that though,
if they'd say Tarantino would fight all his editor who passed away,
but they said that she was such a big piece of his great success because she was
so good at editing his stuff and I heard they would have screaming matches
because you know,
or she didn't agree with her,
but she in a detached way could see what worked from the outside and I certainly
didn't have a yelling match with anyone,
but a lot of times I'm too close to it to see what works and I would have been
totally wrong about this and I would have thrown that promo out and not used it
because I am mostly in it.
Yeah,
you definitely would have been wrong.
Look,
I laughed hard.
I'd never seen it before.
Those are legit lab.
It's always going to be that way though,
Jim.
Yeah,
always going to,
yeah.
You're never going to be totally happy.
That's why you're good.
Yeah,
I guess.
But are you totally happy though?
You have to know what a great I walk in here.
I see like all I think is Rogan makes me feel lazy.
Like,
like,
because you have such a great setup yard,
UFC you,
I don't know how you do this and smoke pot.
You're gonna fucking an ice chamber this morning.
They're always doing this weird shit.
Reading articles.
You're the best follow on Twitter.
I'm like,
how does he fucking keep all these plates spinning and,
but being really good at all of them.
I'm just a fucking lazy cunt.
I go in the morning and do radio.
I jerk off looking@eros.com for nine hours.
I do a spot at the cellar and I get a massage.
Well,
think about those nine hours or you spent jerking off.
You know,
those are hours that you could have done.
All the things that I do.
Exactly.
Do you think?
I don't.
I think about while I'm doing it,
while I'm tugging my Prek,
I'm thinking this could be your green screen fixed,
you know?
Yeah.
I do.
Well with me,
it's,
I'm just real lucky that I found out a
bunch of things that I like doing.
You know,
all the things that I'm interested in,
whether it's the links that I put up on Twitter,
whether it's the articles,
I read,
documentaries,
I watched martial arts,
I do whatever I'm doing,
bow hunting,
whatever I'm doing,
I'm interested in it.
So I'll just,
things I'm interested in.
I think that's like a big part of what life would keeps life fun.
It just be interested in a bunch of different things and pursue those things
with most people.
You can't pursue your real interest because you have a job that's usually not
your real interest.
I've been there too when I was doing fear factor and I'm no,
no,
woe is me.
It was a great gig.
Paid a lot of money's a lot of exposure and all that good stuff,
but I didn't want to do it.
I only did it because they wanted to pay me.
Right.
You know?
And there's a big difference between living like that and living like I live
now.
Whereas everything I do,
I enjoy doing.
Whether I do the UFC or whether I do a podcast or stand up or anything,
I enjoy all my things.
So in that way,
I figured out a way to harmoniously manage my life.
It's nice to not hate it.
Right.
It's fantastic.
I love it.
I mean,
it's not that I love everything I do and there's always,
you know,
even with podcasters podcast that don't go well or I don't like moments in them
and those they will fuck with me and,
and I'll try to,
but they fuck with me because I care because I'm trying to make it better.
And you know,
I'm trying,
when you're doing anything where it's,
it's a flowing sort of living thing,
you're ad libbing and maybe I added too much or maybe I didn't add enough or
maybe I was too low energy or maybe are too high energy.
This Matt,
it was,
you're just,
it's just because you care and if you care and if you're constantly trying to
improve things and you're also taking chances and you're also trying to innovate
and trying to,
you know,
trying to be as loose and open as possible.
It's got to be things that don't go great.
Yes.
And you have to kind of,
you know,
you have to kind of leave the flaws in sometime.
And I,
I,
one of the things I love so much about Mike Douglas,
and this is,
it was such an imperfect thing.
Those shows he's going to be in the Jackson five one time.
And it was all of them.
It was just a very slow interview because they were kids at the time and he said
to one of them,
like,
so I understand you're the prankster.
And he's like,
Yanik playing pranks.
It was like,
it was such a fucking shit moment,
but I love the fact that it was real and they left it in and they didn't fuck
with it.
And nowadays they would go back and they would chop that out to him.
Gallen Prank cry.
Yeah,
I'm Pragar right back.
And it would be jazzed up and fixed.
And in that moment it was kind of like just this is what it is.
It's a natural flow.
Great moments,
slow moments,
but they're all real moments.
And I kind of like what you're saying,
there's going to be little things that bother you because they're real moments
and there are a lot of little things that bother you because you care because
you want to make it,
you want it to be great.
Like I'm way better at doing podcasts now than it was when I first started doing
it will bother you in a podcast.
Like what?
Like I'm not saying for like who did a bad one,
but like what will be a podcast thing that you're like,
fuck man,
that was a bad episode.
Will be the other person didn't talk or you didn't get out of them what you
wanted.
It could be a mistake having them on the first place.
They just,
you know,
they're born as interesting as I thought they were going to be.
Or we don't see eye to eye on things and he gets weird,
which is sometimes fun.
But uh,
sometimes some,
you know,
I've one of my favorite ones,
that skeptic guy,
Brian Dining,
just cause it was so ridiculously off.
It was so off.
Cause he's such a goofy guy.
He was so fucked in the head.
This guy,
it's just his mind was just so like he would go,
he would think he was gonna.
He had a long road ahead of him and he was just kept going off cliffs and Woo
Hoo.
Just something wrong with the way the guy thinks,
but sometimes you'll have a podcast and the guy's just not interesting and I
just don't connect with them.
Or maybe it's me.
Maybe I'm just low energy.
I've had podcasts where I just,
you know,
maybe I was just too exhausted.
They had been doing too many things.
That's definitely,
you have to always manage your energy and if you're doing too many different
things at the same time,
like I do a lot of different things.
It's,
it's a matter of making sure that you have enough.
Do you ever go back,
because one of the guys I interviewed,
one of the episodes is freeway Rick and I know you and he's fucking fascinating.
Great.
But all I think is,
I should have asked him this.
I should.
It's like there's never enough time to ask everything you want to ask.
If you ask good questions,
you're like fuck,
I had to do was that one and that one and that one and I missed it.
I missed it.
I did two podcasts with them,
so I did like six hours where they're talking to him.
Yeah.
The,
the first one though,
I think we really got to the heart of everything because it was three hours long
and you know,
he told everything,
the whole CIA connection to the Iran Contra affair.
And notice I said Contra corner that cause I know how to speak.
I'm very eloquent.
He was a,
he was a fascinating guy and
a very positive guy,
man for God.
I spent that much time in jail and yeah,
very peaceful and very interesting dude and really earnestly working to help
people not make the same mistakes that he made.
He said he was a nice man.
No.
And so it was hard to me to picture that guy in the,
um,
in the role of kingpin.
And then as we were,
we were editing and we weren't chopping content on this one.
It was just camera angles because of the way that I demanded the audience be set
up.
You know you have to,
we couldn't just get a two shot because I didn't know that because I'm a fucking
now this cunt.
So we had to just fix a couple of camera angles and there's a couple of moments
for Rick's talking.
I just saw his face and he was being pleasant,
but I'm like,
oh that's the guy who the king pin,
that's the guy.
And then that,
and then in those moments,
I actually told the editor a couple of times,
rewind that and [inaudible] on his face and he was just listening and he wasn't
angry,
but I saw in that moment that face,
I'm like,
that's the guy that fucking gave the order like in that,
you know what I mean?
Like this nice pleasant man is who he really is.
But you can't be this nice,
pleasant man and fucking make $900 million selling cocaine.
Isn't it crazy how much you made?
He made $900 million.
You can't do it.
You can't be Mr. Nice Guy.
You can't operate with the bloods and the crips together and be a nice fucking
fellow all the time.
There has to be that other part of you.
I hope he's making money now.
I hope he's doing well.
You know how hard must it be when you've made $900 million selling drugs to not
go back to selling drugs?
So not go,
I got to figure out a way to do this and not get caught.
I wonder if it is that I should again,
I should have asked him that but I wonder is also,
is it cause he got life without parole learn,
you know,
learn to read and now he's out.
So is it,
is that overpowered by the fucking fact that you like you know what,
I can fuck a woman if I want to.
I can go get a piece of pizza if I want to.
Like this is the gratitude for being out override the loss of material stuff.
Oh I'm sure it does.
I'm sure it does.
Cause the loss of material stuff was already out the window anyway.
He was in jail and I,
I'm,
I'm sure he,
well,
he's also a changed person,
like a real legitimately changed person,
you know,
and the fact that he didn't even know how to read before he got into jail and
then he got to jail,
learned how to read and then found the legal flaws in the argument against him.
And that's what got him released.
I mean,
that's incredible.
What happened was lawyers,
how many like these be paying lawyers all that money and they don't catch the
fucking,
you know,
it was a three strikes,
you're out law thing.
It was a double jeopardy thing.
Right.
They counted one of them was two strikes but was only you,
it was the same thing twice or something.
Something along those lines.
Yeah.
But he,
I know he doesn't want to be that guy anymore,
which is why he doesn't sell drugs anymore.
But,
uh,
that's gotta be a weird thing to go from like Mc Hammer style from having
hundreds of millions of dollars to how do I pay my bills?
Yeah.
And what do I do from here?
I bigger than MCM or really what's that?
Even bigger.
Yeah.
Cause MC hammer didn't go to,
although I think it would mc hammer went through was harder because he didn't go
to prison for 20 years.
He's have a 20 year cooling off period with no women.
Like you know Mc Hammer just went from fucking from a private plane with 30
people to what the fuck do I do now?
I owe tax money and nothing that he did it on the outside.
Whereas Rick Ross had a lot of years of like this sucks to kind of get his life
and then then be grateful.
What does it Galaxy Mc Hammer do for money?
I don't know.
With Google,
What do I mean what?
What would you do if you were a guy like mc hammer and all of a sudden the
fucking the Gig is up.
They didn't even do the religious thing for awhile.
Yes.
Going to be a pastor of a church or something like that.
Yeah,
I guess he's got a block of money that way or something.
It's got a blog but he hasn't updated it since 2013 November.
That's not good for blogging on the surreal life.
Oh,
was he really?
Three,
he was managing,
um,
martial artists for a while.
He had some company that he was managing martial artists.
What's it think it was called in Alchemy or something like that?
Yeah.
I wouldn't trust him with my money.
If you go through fucking 30 million and I get broke or whatever the amount was,
I don't want to trust you with my financial decisions.
It wasn't an even crazier than that.
Like he was spending like ungodly amounts of money to like refurbish this house
and then they had to stop halfway through it cause he ran out of money.
But it was just some insane thing.
Like the marble alone was like $8 million worth of Italian marble or something.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It's really crazy how people like how fast expense I had shelves built recently.
And why wouldn't they be problems with them?
Because whatever fucking cunt face does something cultured,
it falls apart.
So now the shelves are not there.
They're being rewritten,
spared.
Um,
you know,
and it's like you,
you just realize that they give you an estimate and he always goes more,
well,
he gets to be more and you're like,
you're already in a little bit.
You can't just stop.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's the thing they do to you.
That's the thing.
If a,
especially unscrupulous contractor,
sometimes it's just,
you know,
hidden costs,
they don't see comment.
But some of them they just,
they get you hooked and then once they got you hooked,
they just keep the bills coming.
They do that with car builds to when you're getting a car built.
They did that to me when I was on that show rides where had that Barracuda
built.
It was infuriating,
man.
They treat you like you're a sucker.
Keep adding to it,
right?
Oh,
they treat you like you're a sucker.
They give you a low ball figure.
And then we were past that low ball figure quick and the car was nowhere near
being finished.
And I was like,
guys,
what's going on?
Like what?
What are you doing?
And they were like,
hey,
you know,
it's a,
it's costing a little more than we thought.
It's costing $100,000 more.
Wow.
You guys are like,
what the fuck is going on?
And they started talking about,
look,
you know,
we'll sell it.
You know,
we'll sell it and we'll give you your money back.
Like no the fuck you won't now that's my car.
You're not going to sell.
Because it was on the cover of popular hot rodding or one of those,
you know,
hot rod magazine,
a couple of different magazines.
So they were getting offers people like,
hey Ya,
you know,
I want to see this car.
I'd Bob all this car as this guy,
he wants to sell the car.
And they started getting greedy.
So they started like doing all this crazy shit to the
car to can make it more valuable.
But while they were doing that,
it was costing me more money.
I was financing the whole thing and then they were threatening to sell it and
just give me my money back and they were going to like make all the profit.
I was like,
you guys are comments like,
this is cool.
This is the craziest fucking scenario I'm in.
And it was just like they do with a house,
except it's different because it's your house,
right?
Like this isn't even your car.
Like this is a car that you're paying for.
And this guy's telling me,
hey look,
if you don't want to spend x amount of money,
we'll sell it and we'll give you your money back.
Like the fuck you will.
How'd you find the resolve it?
Uh,
well,
the production company got involved and it got pretty ugly because they ripped
him off to,
it was,
it was pretty bad.
The guy who built it,
he made some mistakes.
It was a,
it was a disaster.
It wasn't chip Foose who was the other guy.
It was a mess.
It was a mess,
a real mess because a bunch of people got really greedy because it was,
the car was getting a tremendous amount of attention.
It,
it was ugly.
I don't know.
They got cut out of,
uh,
my friend Bud's production company though,
who does overhaul and he does a bunch of the shows.
He cut him off forever.
It's like done.
You're done dude.
You're cut off forever.
People just don't see the big picture.
Right?
They don't know.
I mean,
he was all these dollar bill signs are in his head because it was on these
magazine covers and we had this conversation on the phone.
He's like,
look,
you know,
this car is a popular car.
Cars on today.
I go,
Hey,
fuck head.
Why do you think this car is so much more popular than any car you ever built?
You ever think it's maybe because you're building it for a famous person,
you fucking dolt.
Did you not see that?
You think that you're the famous person?
Like,
do you understand this?
Like this is getting you more attention,
that more attention will generate more business for you,
but we have a deal and you,
you're fucking me out of my deal because someone's going to offer you an extra
$30,000 or whatever this other person was offering him.
But that's what they do with cars.
They start you off this,
say,
you know,
we'll build the car for you,
Jimmy,
Kashi,
she about 20,
30 grand,
but prepare,
prepare,
and then you know,
you've got the car.
And then like Jim,
I'm the trainees,
a little more expensive.
We're going to have to adjust the housing and the rear end's not good.
We're gonna have to add a new rear end.
And some of that stuff's legitimate,
but some of it is like a Hee Hee.
Ha Ha.
We gotcha.
Excellent example by the way,
training and the training.
And He,
I know,
I didn't even mean that those things.
And in that way it wasn't meant to be a double entendre,
but,
uh,
it fell into place correctly.
But yeah,
I,
I'm in the middle of a,
a thing with my house that's going great.
And when,
you know,
you have something fixed in your house and someone's doing it and they're doing
a great job and it's all on time,
it's beautiful.
It's like,
ah,
the guy did what he said he was going to do and everything's working out well.
It's like it's,
it's like relaxing.
He didn't know it.
He didn't fuck me.
I'm going to ask it again.
Wow.
This is incredible.
This is the third time.
Let's just wrap this thing up.
We're done.
Anyway,
all I done.
Okay,
we're done.
So vice vice.com where old people do be able to see this on vice.com Wednesday
the 23rd it comes out and I'll of course I'll be tweeting about it and the first
episode tweeting about it as well.
Wednesday the 23rd please.
Anything you need promoted.
When can people see you live doing stand up.
Um,
I am doing in Montreal
that Jesus Theater and I got a bunch of stuff on Jim norton.com cause I cobb's
August 7th,
eighth and ninth.
Ah,
cobb's in San Francisco.
Wonderful place to visit if you want to get jerked off tickets available.
I've never gone there and gotten jerked up.
Dare you.
Oh really?
Run my room.
I have roadmaps.com you'll find a lot of good places out there.
We just wander around the city.
There's wonderful places.
Thanks for having me man.
Last time.
My brother,
anytime.
If you guys wind up doing a podcast,
I would love to be one of your guests.
Let's do it.
We'll see what happens.
It's going to happen.
He can't be held down anymore.
It's,
we can't allow it.
We can't allow it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the Opie and Anthony Show will continue.
It must,
it must with serious or without the,
through the Gottman has been laid down.
Uh,
thank you everybody.
Thanks for,
uh,
thanks for tuning into the podcast.
Thanks for our sponsors.
Who Do we have today?
Uh,
we had,
thanks Tony Tang.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save yourself some money.
You dirty bitches.
Save yourself $25 off of any brand new glorious phone from a wonderful company.
Thanks also to blue apron,
my new favorite sponsor,
not my new favorite,
but I love them.
They're great.
I'm going to eat tonight,
blue apron.com/brogan.
Go there and get your first two meals for free.
That's blue apron.com/rogan thanks also to on at.com go to o.
N N.
I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
We'll be back next week with a lot of Mo,
a lot of most show,
uh,
until then,
enjoy yourselves,
have a good time and uh,
be loving to each other.
Big Kiss.
I want to say.